the protest
in dc is officially starting tomorrow
and tomorrow's the fifth
now when they initially announced it
they said you know trump tweeted out be
there on the sixth it's going to be wild
and then other people started announcing
that they were actually gonna start
getting there a little bit early i
wouldn't be surprised if people are
already there now
in fact no i take the back they are
already there now because the breaking
news is that enrique tario
chairman of the proud boys has been
arrested in washington dc
and this is because he went on parlor
and claimed that he destroyed a banner
in dc at a previous event where they
took a black lives matter banner and
burned it
so that's the reason i believe they also
found two high-capacity magazines which
is
interesting as he was driving into
washington dc
wonder why he would have those maybe
just were in the car or something or on
him i have no idea but we'll read into
the story
and now they're saying the national
guard is being deployed because they
think things are going to start picking
up getting a little spicy
i myself got a notification from my
hotel that things are expected to get
well they didn't say the end is nigh
they said heads up city's locked down
until the 15th for these reasons eat in
your room if you want to enjoy our fine
dining and these roads are all closed so
keep that in mind
we'll see how things play out we got a
handful of guests who are
here to we'll actually talk about this
stuff we got elijah shaffer who's who's
hanging out elijah how's it going
dude it's going pretty good i had to get
kind of early because i'm afraid they're
going to shut down the whole city like
they did last time then you can't
even get off the freeway because they
shut down the exits it's like kind of
insane
right on we also got drew hernandez who
you're going to be down there on the
ground too i guess right
um yeah yep cat's out the bag oh why was
i not supposed to say
that's all good i mean no he's not going
to be there i i'm not going to be there
yeah don't come after me yeah and then
uh of course uh lukakowski's hanging out
i have not yet been voted off of this
island
and i am continuing my indentured
servitude here thanks for having me
but uh i think we're all gonna be down
there tomorrow so
uh first thing is you know we're gonna
have a crew go down and test the
internet at the hotel to make sure it
works but it's a prime location it's
like
it's like right there so we're gonna be
able to see what's going on and
if we can get a strong and capable
signal while these prices are going on
then i should be coming down for the six
and doing this show
live probably from the hotel we'll see
how things go but that should get uh uh
you know we'll see how things plan to be
interesting i'm gonna do something we
haven't done on this show
ever before actually i don't think we've
ever done this and i'm gonna
i'm gonna give a shout out to a sponsor
that we actually have
ladies and gentlemen helping us make
this show today is safeandreadymeals.com
you can check it out if you're
interested it is emergency food supplies
for a two-week emergency food supply
it's like you know pancake mix macaroni
and cheese it's 97 bucks you can get a
four week supply for 197 bucks i was
thinking about it
i'm like all your food needs for two
weeks for a hundred bucks actually a
pretty good deal
but here's what i say to people i'm not
telling you to buy this stuff because
the end of the world is coming or
anything like that
i just think it's reasonable if you got
a first aid kit you have some
extra water you know laying around maybe
just in a closet and you've got some
emergency food it's usually what i tell
people
i always i always ask people do you know
do you even know where your first aid
kit is and most people don't
so i'll tell you this if you want to
support the show you want to get a good
deal on these
emergency food supplies not too
expensive hundred bucks you can go to
safeandreadymeals.com
it really does help out the show thanks
for listening to that sponsor spot
but let's start talking about the news
from fox 5
dc proud boys leader enrique tario
arrested in dc
police say fox 5 has learned and
mkhitaryan has been arrested
evan lambert reports tario is facing
misdemeanor destruction of property
charges in relation
to him saying he burned a black lives
matter flag that was stolen from a black
church in december
during a protest in the district lambert
tweeted two law enforcement sources
confirmed and ricky taurio has been
arrested
on dc misdemeanor destruction of
property charges d.c police confirmed
monday evening they'd arrested the 36
year old
he has been charged with destruction of
property related that offense police say
at the time of his arrest tario is found
to be in possession of two high-capacity
firearm magazines
he has been additionally charged with
possession of high-capacity feeding
device
so i guess that's related to the
magazines that's the crazy thing people
don't know about dc
you can't even own ammo oh you have to
get a register you have to get
registered to own ammunition it's like a
lot of places don't even do that some of
the craziest places
it's all about the guns they say earlier
on monday the metropolitan african
methodist episcopal church in dc
filed a lawsuit against the proud boys
and tario alleging that the group scaled
its fence and tore down a large black
lives matter sign on display
it was one of two historically black
churches that were vandalized during the
protests
so they made that statement and they
called it like they were saying it was a
hate crime and stuff like that
and so it was a bunch of proud boys who
apparently done it in my opinion i don't
think you should be
you know taking private property and
burning and destroying it because i'll
criticize antifa for the same thing
but i guess because they were calling it
racist and ricky tario who's not a white
man
posted on parlor that it was actually
him and and he said something like
i dare you to charge me with a hate
crime are you guys familiar with
what he posted oh yeah and actually we
were there that night and we saw this
stuff i think you were
you were there right beside me and i can
tell you two things number one
nobody knew these were black churches so
like this idea there was a bunch of
white people walking around hunting
black churches number one
this is washington dc so the chance of a
church probably being a majority black
church is pretty high since this is a
very
dense black community but number two if
you understand the entire political
spectrum of proud boys there's like two
groups they oppose
and that's antifa anarchists and then
like communist backed groups
which many people who helped found blm
claim to be behind yeah so they weren't
seeing this i believe
well i i obviously think it's kind of
stupid to tear something down and just
like burn it off of private property
i don't think this was a target on black
people i think this was like we're
taking down a communist symbol in a city
and showing that it's
we're taking it back for america but
that's what i saw and that's what i
thought their motives were
i think the funny part about it is like
since when the hell does black lives
matter care about church
like i um listen we were there we were
recovered we were covering that right
on a saturday night the next morning
black lives matter dc held a presser
in blm plaza crying and complaining
saying that their black joy was stolen
and that all of a sudden they care about
church all of a sudden they care about
these historic black churches and it's
like
these are the same people that don't
want any form of religion even whether
it's jesus whatever it is
completely out of society so all of a
sudden black lives matter cares about
church but they just arrested a black
guy for doing it
and rickettario yeah literally he's like
he's half he's half black
they always try is he cuban or puerto
rican he's he's they were
they report that he's afro-cuban yeah so
i guess
you know i think it's really dumb
because i don't i don't like playing
those games on race with people
like i shouldn't have to bring that up
about what enrique's race is or anybody
here
yeah but you got to flip it on their
head man but when they say it was a
bunch of white dudes stealing you know
black joy or whatever it's like
actually the guy who claimed he's
claiming he did it i don't know if he
was he was that he did but
i mean it sounds reasonable but he's
he's like the proud boy he was there
can we just say this though that night
this happened not only were a couple
proud boys
stabbed um from what i remember right
weren't they critical yeah they were
stabbed
but also can we also can also point this
out that antifa were also looking to
attack proud boys at this time
black lives matter the organization the
group shut down dc they were grouped
together
trying to attack the proud boys police
had to keep them off so this wasn't like
a war between white people and black
churches even worse there was a battle
between blm
antifa activists and and the proud boys
and so they're like kind of like how
antifa keeps ripping down american flags
and burning them
because they think that proud boys
symbolize american patriotism they kind
of went back and said well let's rip
down their signs too
stupid probably but stupid you know i
think it's even worse than that elijah
because
they're they're not only going after
proud boys
antifa black lives matter and dc are
going after innocent trump supporters
you have like elderly couples you have
young people that just support the
president
that are walking down black lives matter
plaza just back to their hotels getting
physically assaulted because of
supporting the president so it's like
the media will take this and say oh the
proud boys are attacking black people
but the reason why the proud boys
responded was because
innocent trump supporters were being
physically assaulted all night long the
past two events
and the mpd because they have their
hands tied they just kind of
shoo them away and continue and move on
and move on one of the top stories on
reddit just a few days ago was this
church
actually suing the proud boys and now we
have the washington post
confirming that he was arrested
specifically for
burning the black lives stolen banner
this is washington post just reporting
on it right now
is it for the arson or for the theft
it's misdemeanor property destruction
it was it was like something now dc
cares
about property destruction it's great
right
this is the timeline we find ourselves
no but but look at what's going on right
now with like that leaked phone call
from trump
right it's a leaked phone call and
twitter's like oh that's fine
didn't we just go through this huge news
cycle of like you can't release people's
private information
or them doing specific substances with
uh i'm not even gonna say the double
standard
is pal but this is the point i want to
get to that's actually it's actually
pretty worrying man
when the proud boys romped around dc
there's a video of them
really just clobbering this antifa dude
now apparently
there's like an antifa guy who was
fighting with him got separated from his
group him and this chick
and then the proud boys just would not
relent this guy's trying to leave he's
clearly lost the fight and the proud
boys run up one one guy grabs the woman
a proud boy a guy grabs a woman by her
ponytail and like pulls her hair back
and i'm like dude that is that is that
is loser antifa style fighting
grabbing a woman's hair from behind and
point you're a dude come on but
repeatedly pummeling this guy the santa
dude as he's clearly no threat to you or
anybody else
then they went and they tore down that
sign out my response was like
sounds a whole lot like what antifa does
i'm not a fan of that if you want to
defend yourself from antifa
you you should you should absolutely
defend yourself from somebody wants to
beat you up who's
attacking you or defend others but when
they're running away tail between their
legs pathetic let them go
yeah but see drew brought this up and i
think this is where people don't
understand i'm not defending
the violence because my i myself am not
of like an extremely violent person
not even mildly violent people even like
discredit me or try to slap me on the
face for the fact that like oh hey
you know you should fight back a little
more and defend yourself but when i see
those events you have to look at the
whole timeline and from the very
beginning
these antifa groups which are often
protected by the mpd they have
a reserve base it's the black lives
matter plaza
which essentially i think it's like 14th
street or whatever right there by the
white house yeah right right by
lafayette plaza uh park
and they get they they run back to this
area protected by police then they come
out
of the sides the police let them leave
and come back but nobody else so if you
look like you're
in black block or whatever you can go in
and out i've experienced this if i'm
wearing black block i can get in dress
like a journalist no
so you go in they come out they like
fireworks
they assault people with skateboards
they punch people they hit people
all the time like i watch this happening
so when the proud boys aren't just like
going there and being like
let's go pummel some antifa let's go
pummel some black lives matter it's like
these guys are extremely masculine men
who
a lot of them it's a part of a club i'm
sure a lot of them feel a lot of the
same reasons why people might join
antifa they might have been
you know feel a little bit rejected from
society some of them and they found a
lot of camaraderie and brotherhood
there's some positive elements here
but they get riled up because the
violence starts happening and they go
and somebody's always like
we need to fight back we need to show
these people they can't keep assaulting
us if the police won't step in
then we will but here here's the point i
want to make the proud boys used to be
very conscious about press
they'd be very very careful they'd make
sure they know the media is looking to
smear them all the time
so they would try their best but no
matter what the proud boys do
they're a far-right white supremacist
group literally you got
enriquetario not a white guy and they
claim he's a white supremacist it's a
weirdest thing this this
so when they when i think they've come
to the point now the proud boys have
realized
there's no point in even trying to do
the right thing yeah as
as as far as the press cares because
they're going to get lied about anyway
so now they're just like screw it we're
going we're going to we're going to go
out and
and you know we're going to do what
antifa does why not spot on the
relationship between antifa and the
police is something that's
really peculiar because there have been
many documented instances of police
officers
dressing up as antifa and then
committing property destruction
as has happened throughout many protests
and now to hear your reports of them
kind of coddling them like what's the
most egregious example that you saw of
this or
or like how would you what would you say
sticks out to you most uh this is how
this is how it goes down um you will
literally see
on one of these nights you will
literally see antifa black lives matter
start they they start these violence
they start these violent acts they'll go
after
innocent trump supporters it's not proud
boys you'll see like elderly couples
walking down the street
teenagers young kids the first mega
rally
was they were holding down the fort
black lives matter plaza
they issue out text messages saying we
have to defend our territory we have to
defend blm plaza
and whoever's wearing a trump hat
whether it's an elderly person or a
young kid
they will go to town on them so when
that happens the police will just shoo
them away
and then the proud boys will see that
like all night long and then they'll
respond to the violence and come out on
the streets
because the mpd isn't doing much but
what you do see
is when the proud boys come out the mpd
will literally grab antifa grab black
lives matter
pull them behind behind the lines behind
them they shield them to protect them
i don't care what anybody says if anyone
wants to accuse me oh you're an activist
reporter i don't care i don't care at
this point there will literally be times
where i'm watching this and i'm like
these are the same people that have been
calling to defund the police
all year long and there they are being
defended by the police
and they they receive it we just saw
that in what salem washington yeah
where an auntie of a guy armed with a
paintball gun is standing
with his back to the cops staring at
proud boys and the pro
is not even all proud by some
conservatives the craziest thing
seeing conservatives yell at the police
yeah i saw there was a dude
who looked like he was wearing proud
boys colors and he's screaming after the
police
f the blue and then you see that video
it's from ford fisher
where they actually throw the thin blue
line flag on the ground and start
stomping on it and then just chuck it
into the street
police got no support left man well it
blows my mind i think the best example
to your point of this
is so there was polish state media that
were at the last
march okay and uh antifa had made an
actual people say it's not a real thing
well they had a flyer
and it said black block anarchist
everyone meet at this park so it's this
circle that i think it's like jefferson
circle or something i don't remember
what it's called
they all meet together so polish state
media probably not super hyper aware of
what's going on in the streets of
america
goes to film then i start seeing they're
like on the outskirts the black blocks
start coming up you know saying you
can't film here
you can't do this and they're saying i
can film whatever i want wait you guys
have freedom of press here you know in
their accents you have freedom of press
i know my rights here i know what i can
do and another journalist who's american
media i'm not going to say where from
was saying oh no you obviously don't
realize the rules of antifa so
they're going uh you know journalists
saying that they follow the rules of
anarchists
uh and so then it goes further the guy
goes he's getting a kick out of him he's
a pole right polls don't mess around
so he's just like keeps filming and he's
like luke and they're
pushing i got beat up a couple times
police are there and they're pushing the
camera guy
and they're hitting the camera and the
police are standing there and
this is i mark my words i spoke to these
guys the next day i i did hear it right
i filmed this incident it was on twitter
they're pushing him back pushing him
back into the police and he's telling
the police why don't you help me
and the officer was like dude well you
shouldn't have been accosting them and
he's like
i wasn't accosting them i'm filming them
like i'm with i'm a press member like
look and the
officer was like dude look man just
don't be bothering them and you're like
was that election night
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah how did how did
this flip happen
where it's like the left has been
screaming the proud boys walk up to a
cop and shake their hand and they're
like the police are practicing the
protecting the proud boys and now it's
inverted
yeah a very similar thing happened to me
in hamburg when i got jumped by antifa
police officer came looked at me he was
like uh we can't help you you're screwed
good luck
and then literally i got followed back
and and you were there and it was just
the crazy insane incident
the crazy the crazy thing is how the mob
mentality works like some dude just
pointed at luke and accuse him of being
a fascist and then
random people run up and start punching
luke in the head
you know i saw something i saw a video
of yours old school video bro i thought
it was
awesome from when you were i think you
were in new york i don't know where you
were
but you were covering antifa and it it
it kind of shocked me because
i think antifa was literally like on the
sidewalks
and i was filming them like i think it's
when you got tearing up tires and you
got hit
time when you got assaulted i was there
too the first and i remember a guy
walking
no no no no no second time that was the
second time but i remember the second
time was also kind of prominent because
i remember
i saw this guy walking behind you i'm
like that he's going to jump on him
and then and then no no no no i was like
i was getting ready
it worked no yes i was filming matt
grabbed him and i
uh oh that's right and i grabbed his
mask off and took his mask off and then
it was absolutely
what year was that what year was that
was 2012 it was the beginning of 2012.
this is what stuck out to me what stuck
out to me was how antifa
i remember hearing like police calls on
the intercoms
in the video what stuck out to me was
how antifa would actually listen to
orders to get on the sidewalks in march
is that accurate would they literally
march on the sidewalks yeah of course of
course uh and now that now they're just
the whole
well it's about choosing their battles
right at the time back then it was like
you want to fight for the cops to do it
covertly don't let them arrest you
arbitrarily
so then you know they would do things
like d arrests well because it was
anarchy what's weird is is anarchies
like the police are against you but now
the police
protect them i actually okay this is a
weird way to segue but i actually
brought a gift for you guys i'm being
serious this is a rare gift i'm not even
joking
this is only like a couple of these
around i want you to open this it's not
inappropriate on air
boy i want you to know it's not
inappropriate and i really want you to
keep this this is actually a
a historic historic piece it's a story
piece i only have four of these
i'll explain to you what this is so this
is
a hat that i saved out of a bonfire in
ilhan omar's district
during the trump rally when the police
cordoned all of the
trump supporters uh to walk through the
antifa and they were ripping everyone's
hats off
and lit them on fire i took a few out of
the fire and put them out
and saved them to remember the violence
and the abuse that was going on and i
remember during that time when i was
filming that
you know people were saying like why
aren't the police doing anything this
was like a shock at that point
saying how could the police be
protecting those who are assaulting
trump supporters and i go well
clearly this shows you that the police
while many officers
are great individuals who just love
their city and they're trying to protect
and serve or just make a living
this shows you that that police are
under the influence of their district of
their city and there's a lot of
bureaucracy and political
corruption that's involved in what
police can and cannot do and when i
watched that and that's why i kept these
hats i think the only person who has one
is glenn beck
but thank you sir but i wanted you
because i knew you'd actually keep that
definitely that's that's a relic to show
you
like that's a failure of the police in
our state right now where the fact is is
that if that can happen if people can
get their property stolen
illegal fires could get lit and guess
who i kept seeing getting arrested for
fighting back
trump supporters of course of course so
one of the first events i went to
i've been covering we didn't we didn't
call him antifa back during the occupy
wall street days we call them black
block anarchists or whatever
but they're not anarchists like i was
friends with the anarchists you want to
know why
because anarchists real anarchists be it
left
anarchists or right anarchists don't
believe in using violence against people
yeah the non-aggression principle
i'm very very left libertarian i don't
believe in you know anarchy is and
without archie authority
i'm not that you know far libertarian on
the spectrum but i'm pretty left
libertarian on a lot of issues
and so i was hanging out at occupy wall
street and i'll tell you
the actual anarchists were complaining
the whole time saying
sitting down having a discussion like
convincing people of how we all work
together and cooperate
is anarchy not one person beating the
other
demanding they do as they're told that's
fascism that's authoritative that's what
they were saying
the left using force and extersion to
push your ideas is something that's bad
i mean that's
widely accepted by a lot of anarchists
and there was a lot of very
interesting smart discussions at occupy
wall street which i think you know
i think that that kind of sentiment this
is interesting because we really have to
talk about the kind of political climate
right now
because i bet there's going to be a lot
of left wingers that are going to be
very disenfranchised with joe biden
there's also a lot of right-wingers that
are absolutely pissed off at the
authorities especially the police
officers
this saturday it was ezra levant posting
even admitting himself a rebel like his
conservative very conservative a
canadian a canadian
which is absolutely fascinating but
there is a political realignment the
climate is changing and i think there's
going to be some major fireworks
especially
this year well so i guess what's going
to happen is i think you'll start seeing
i wonder if uh we have these we have
these three factions i wonder if the
populists
will have a tacit agreement of some sort
right so this is something that jenk
yuger of the young turks wrote about
recent uh recently he said there's three
different realities there's
the populist left the establishment and
populist right well he
he claims to be a populist leftist i
disagree i think he's actually very very
very pro-establishment
and i think he just you know his bread
and butter is the progressive track i
really do think so
you look at like you know jimmy dore who
was saying like why can't we get a vote
for medicare for all and this is the big
big scandal going on right now jenk
huger and jimmy were trending on twitter
earlier
so anyway digress he's right he's right
and so you know i'll give him respect
for for
this op-ed he wrote the one thing he got
wrong was very derisive of trump
supporters saying they're cultists and
stuff like that you don't need to go
there because you can just talk about
the populist left hates the
establishment the populist right hates
the establishment
with trump being pushed out of power
that means you're going to have two
out-of-power populist factions who hate
the establishment if there's three
realities here
and two of them are united in their
hatred of the establishment
will antifun the leftists look the other
way when proud boys are the ones you
know yelling at cops and screaming and
the proud boys announced
that this specific week that we saw this
in a post by enrique talking about maybe
we should wear
all black maybe we should not identify
ourselves as prod boys so that's also
another contributing factor to what's
kind of
happening here and how it's unfolding
because i really do think the
establishment is deathly afraid of these
sides coming together because
they're going to realize they have a lot
more in common than they have different
from each other what happens
when proud boys and conservatives do
show up tomorrow
on the sixth and the or tomorrow are on
the six and they are in black block when
that so if those aren't familiar it's
like they're wearing you know black
sweaters and black pants and masks or
whatever
you won't be able to tell the difference
between anti-fun and proud voice and
smell yeah that's right
what are the police gonna do what are
the cops gonna do yeah and what is
how is antiever going to fight proud
boys if they all look the same how are
proud boys going to fight antifa
i suppose if you're in disguise as
antifa you know
i'll hit somebody else but what if a
proud boy punches a proud boy thinking
he's antifa
the point is i got knocked down in
seattle i was in i was in block
and a proud boy once punched me in the
shoulder and knocked me down
from a shoulder punch well he went like
he's a oh you don't know some of these
dudes
yeah the viral video yeah well i was
just standing there i'm not like in a
defensive position i was just standing
like boom and i just like why didn't
like fall down i just was like whoa and
like
i was like damn i was like no wonder why
did antifa get knocked down
[Laughter]
what'd you say what'd you do afterwards
oh i was like dude i'm not like antifa
as you even though i'm dressed as antipa
how do you do that
yeah but that's that's that's that's the
why they dress it all black because they
want to create confusion
yeah but so there was a tactic it's a
very important tactic so they don't get
recognized by the police officers
because they're out they all mesh in
and we saw this tactic not just used in
the united states but also very
prominently in hong kong
where they use black bloc tactics to an
amazing extent
to a point where they don't even have to
assault the press they just have a team
of umbrella people come around
and set up this huge umbrella circle
around them and they and
they never assaulted journalists they
never told them not to film they just
set up these umbrella things and it was
way more difficult
yeah and they were able to galvanize a
lot of these people i mean in hong kong
they're literally protesting for their
lives
there's people disappearing right now
from china because they made a facebook
post or a social media post against the
chinese government
we'll get into the big we got a big
story i just got i just got it i just
got a text from i'm not going to say who
but
very very prominent political
commentator freaking out over this big
story about what's going on with this
with jack ma we'll get to that but i
don't want to gloss over what's going
what's going to happen right now
we got more breaking news and this is
this is
best time to jump right into it pentagon
approves dc mayor's request to deploy
national guard for upcoming
demonstrations cnn reports that
acting defense secretary christopher
miller on monday approved a request for
the mayor of washington
to deploy dc national guard forces to
the city to support local authorities
during pro-trump demonstrations
scheduled in the city this week a
defense official told cnn
mayor muriel bowser made the request
thursday in a letter addressed to major
general william j
walker uh the commanding general of the
dc national guard
in which she referenced protests in the
city in november and december that
resulted in a large influx of
participants
dc police chief robert conti told
reporters on monday the national guard
will assist with crowd management and
traffic control
freeing the city's police officers to
focus on potential acts of violence
and other security issues let me tell
you what i find particularly interesting
about this
the washington post released an op-ed by
10
former secretaries of defense defense
secretaries
all of them said involving the military
in election disputes is dangerous
a lot of people a lot of articles popped
up where they said defense secretaries
are worried trump is going to stay jakku
and things like that or they fear that
trump will use the military for these
reasons
maybe but there's something they said
that was particularly interesting
in the op-ed they said we are calling
upon christopher miller
acting secretary of defense to uphold
the peaceful transition
and they they also said any civilian or
military
who support trump in using the military
to subvert this election
will face potential criminal you know uh
penalties and things of
things of that nature they're basically
saying
you better not if trump gives you the
order but they don't understand you know
uh
trump's not going to come out and order
them to just take over the country it's
not going to work that way
but they're basically i think the point
of this op-ed was to tell
trump's new acting secretary of defense
by name they said we call upon him
not to support the president here's the
thing you gotta understand about chris
miller
donald trump removed the top civilian uh
leadership at the pentagon
replaced it with people who are fans of
trump
so now you've got people in the pentagon
ordering the national guard or approving
it
trump supporters now you've got dc
tomorrow at the biggest trump supporting
event we probably will ever see
tomorrow in the sixth trump's new acting
secretary of defense saying
yes we would like the national guard to
be deployed to dc
and what happens if all these trump
supporters are on the ground and the
cops are doing something and then they
just
order the national guard to defend the
right to peacefully protest or something
like that is that why bowser ordered
that the national guard wouldn't be
armed she was like
basically saying that what she said yeah
i think in politico
i think that might be the same one she
was like he said we have guns bowser
ordered national guard personnel no arms
when responding to protests and they
that they will not perform surveillance
searches or seizures of protesters
this is this is really interesting
because we just had look
this op-ed from the washington post
clearly these former defense secretaries
are worried that miller
would say to the military like we're not
leaving
why would they write it unless they were
at some concerns that could happen
the fact that they said you could face
criminal penalties if you do this it was
like an
open letter warning if you lose that
fight if you come out for trump
and you lose we will lock you up right
christopher miller is not saying
yes of course the the national guard
please you know deploy them into dc
where all of our supporters will be or
is that
looking to it looking too deep into it
is miller just saying i don't know the
mayor asked for it we're fine whatever
well you
gotta look at two things here number one
if we can go back to summer
uh where we had the same problem where
the mayor did not want
national guard deployed when there was
actual civil unrest
there was real violence occurring and
assault on federal property
right and so there were even though i
know technically national guard isn't a
federal branch of the military people
say
you know if you're getting into
semantics but technically it's still
military
when federal property and the people's
house was under attack she was saying
you know this is not what we want we
don't need anything like that she wasn't
just saying that she painted
the slogan in washington dc and then
later was also attacked by the very
activists she was supposedly supporting
but i'm saying like this is where we
have to look at what's what's ironic
about this as we switch into the new
year
is that around this time i remember like
the intercept which is extremely
dishonest publication in many ways so
they do
since we're on your show i'll give them
some credence they have some some great
journalists still at work they're used
to
a broken clock as well twice a day but
they used to have glenn greenwald and
for that i've given him
right not so much anymore not so much
but but i remember that one of their
biggest criticisms
of even early on in the protest is they
were basically saying
oh elijah is you know basically such a
trick artist that he would try to
manipulate his
footage so that trump would fall for his
ploy to try to deploy
a national guard into dc like like these
publications were mocking like wait
hold on they claimed you were trying to
selectively editing
they said that trump fell for my
selectively edited videos when he called
upon them
to say that that's why we need national
guard in dc is if me filming a live
event is
selective editing however i'm just going
to say this the media just a few months
ago was mocking journalists
for providing evidence for the national
guard being present
there was evidence for it trump was
calling for it and they were saying how
dare you that's such a stupid thing
now there's not even any evidence that
there will be mass violence there has
been no violence yet
and they're going hell yeah just put
these guys out there because there's a
trump supporters and we've got to do
what i mean prepare for a war
well black lives matter for the past two
months dc has been putting pressure on
the mayor
putting pressure on hotels hotels have
been shut down
saying that they're housing white
supremacists that are coming to commit
violent acts not even true black
it so people interesting that these
people
are literally they're literally the ones
that are totally anti-law enforcement
anti-police anti-everything but now
i can almost guarantee you that this
mayor called the national guard
to protect black lives matter posts the
mask slipped
i'm sorry no no the mask was ripped
clean off we know black lives matter is
not anti-cop
because there's a video from will from
wisconsin in the milwaukee area
where black lives matter shows up to
this guy's house and they're screaming
and flashing lights
in his house the guy pulls up a shotgun
to the window and he points it
probably a bad idea but he's defending
his own home he didn't shoot anybody
the cops go into his house and they'll
cheer and clap and yeah he's getting
arrested woo they're happy about it
i thought they wanted to to abolish or
defund the cops no i think they're just
communists
communist subverters i think they're
just subverting the constitution
let me ask you do you guys think that
the majority of
armed forces men and women support
donald trump
i would say it's a mix of people who
just want a job and people who who are
patriotic like
i say honestly when i talk to people in
the armed services this is very
unpopular opinion
but when i talk to people a lot of
people that i know got into the armed
services because
they just wanted to either clean up
their life they didn't know what else to
do
and or they also like were tired of not
being respected and they wanted to do
something honorable which is a total
honorable way
and then there's this other half of
people that that i knew uh that are not
necessarily from los angeles where i
grew up
but people from like orange county let's
say more red areas goddamn
they're republican and they love this
nation of the people who just want a job
are they not politically active then do
they not really care well
like how many how many what percentage
of the military do you think supports
trump over biden or vice versa
well it depends because when you look at
support
for from the military one of the things
that really sticks out to mind
to me and then the first thing i think
about is how ron paul was able to get
most of the u.s military servicemen to
support him during his presidential run
we saw donald trump echo some of those
similar kind of epithets and talking
points as ron paul did
so there probably is some kind of
significant base of support
but whether it's still there from his
inauguration is another question
is the leadership there that's that's my
question that's i don't mean for his
inauguration i just mean no but
does the leadership because to me what i
think is that for from my from my
understanding and really talking to
people who serve might come from a
family
of everybody's serving i'm kind of
breaking that uh that generational uh
service but
but usually you talk to soldiers you
talk to to gruntmen you even talk to
officers
and they usually talk about ultimately
when i'm in battle when i'm in war
there's some sort of leader above me
that i trust ultimately
that if they told me if like the
president said we're going to war and
they told me no stay in your barracks
do not leave right now i'm staying in my
barracks i'm not leaving now i might
anybody who's in the service can correct
me on this
these are just people i've spoken to
they have their allegiance to some sort
of commanding officer so what i would be
more concerned about
is not whether gruntman or whether or
whether just officers
are supporting trump but is there enough
people in command and leadership
that have the authority to command those
troops not even like really high ranking
like
medium like a couple hundred like i'm
saying they might command a couple
hundred i don't know how the ranking
filing works for all
like not generals you know i'm i'm
saying that commanders
yeah commanders and people who there
there could be
uh there's what people need to
understand about that you know these uh
these defense secretaries worried about
trump in a military action thing
you don't you don't need to worry about
the generals ordering the military to
support trump that's not likely
it's going to be if there's people in dc
who are mid-rank with a decent amount of
men beneath them and they just tell them
to do something
because they're defending the president
they know maybe they're defying orders
of their commanding officer but they're
like the president
you know says to do this or want
something will there be people loyal to
the president
over say their immediate commanding
officer i'm not entirely convinced that
would be the case like we talked about
this before the show most people
probably just be like i trust my
commanding officer they know them
but the bigger issue at hand is when it
comes to the national guard being
deployed it's coming from with the
approval of christopher miller who is
like they say a trump loyalist right
maybe that's just kind of a way to
drag him but trump did put him in
recently
what i'm telling people is you if you
are wrong if you think
these national guard dudes are going to
be ordered to stage a coup like there's
going to be some high-ranking dude who
says
we're all we're all here for trump it's
time to retake this country charge and
then we're gonna seize the white house
it's never gonna happen
what i'm worried about is if miller or i
don't know to what degree he can
actually order these dudes around maybe
he can't
but if some like uh officer says hey
guys can you just uh uh stand guard
around the white house while this
protest is going on
and then that is the order that is used
by trump or whatever to maintain control
or something
like people think the order is going to
be overt you're going to know what it is
a lot of these guys are going to hear
from their commanding officer hey we're
going to be guarding this bridge right
here you know there's some concerns
about potential for violence and they'll
go okay you got it because it sounds
reasonable right
then it turns out the actual reason for
guarding the bridge was to shut down
some kind of flow of traffic that would
benefit trump
long story short you don't know what the
the the
those at the top really really want
they'll give you what sounds like an
innocuous order
and it could be the order that is used
to stage a coup or do something like
that you know what i mean
well that's how it's meant to be right
you just take orders and don't ask any
questions
right history dictates that too but what
i'm saying is
why would you ask questions if they said
okay we're standing guard at this bridge
right here guys there's going to be a
big protest so uh stand guard
don't let anybody through you know only
if they're credentialed and have
security clearance or whatever
and then you get say some democrat you
know who's trying to get to congress
and the bridge is shut down and like
sorry sir you can't come this way and
they're like i'm in congress i don't
care
i got my orders nobody crosses this
bridge they don't know
it's not it's not unreasonable there's
more national guard here than there were
in kenosha let's put that into
perspective that's right
like actual city blocks of america were
being burned down and this was like
about three nights of this and the
leadership didn't even deploy this many
national guards how many did you know
you know i know that they said that they
were going to activate somewhere between
like 250 and 350 and i can't
i can tell you the exact number i
probably didn't see more than 30 to 40
i saw five different vehicles at least
five vehicles
um during this i might remind you this
was a time when there was a terrorist
attack on on
national soil buildings were burned to
the ground while there were children
inside
um multiple city blocks i mean i think
they said there was now three dozen
buildings that were destroyed
police evacuating right so this was a
serious uh emergency in our in our
country that was going on
and there was not this many national
guard deployed
and so when you have to put this into
perspective here um they say well
kenosha was a small city well so is dc
i mean retrospectively to the actual
area it's like just a few city blocks
when you're talking about these protests
and where they shut down even for the
inaugural parade it's not that large of
an area
well so but how many people were in
kenosha writing
well that's but that's my point though
is that the national guard was there but
they didn't do anything meaning like you
were saying about taking the orders is
my point is they just kind of stayed by
the courthouse sure
and they just stayed and guarded this
while the city burned and that's to your
point is that
the national guard is just taking orders
they're not doing luke what they want
luke you told me a story about i think
it was the g20 in pittsburgh where
all of you told me this story a long
time ago that you had everybody standing
in a park
and then the police were ordered to to
stand around the park
and then when people got bored they all
left and the cops were just standing
looking into an empty park for like you
know a certain amount of time
do you remember that you told me a story
yep yep yep a lot of them just blindly
follow orders even when they don't
completely make sense and that that was
the time i got the crap beat out of me
pepper sprayed handcuffs
literally yeah handcuffed you encircled
everyone nothing it was
i was there as i usually am you know or
was during these kind of events and
they just literally encircled everyone
and they started closing in and in and
they
set up a you know a perimeter closed
everyone in you try to get out they beat
the crap out of you with batons i got a
couple batons
handcuffed to everyone and then i
remember when they were pepper spraying
random people who would just
talk about their rights or saying hey
this is bad this is illegal you
shouldn't be
arresting people who are just here
protesting and they just like
literally we're amazing people
conservatives say they're getting pepper
sprayed in their eyes they're like
but listen it's breaking it's breaking
so so i always say is like
well i'll tell you right now
unfortunately the good cops have quit
that's the scariest thing
we need the good cops to literally stop
the bad cops
but you see these videos of the cops
just being like i quit you know i can't
do this anymore i don't want to be
involved in this
and so the guys who are like i refuse to
follow this order i won't do this are
leaving
and then you're getting the equivalent
of scabs you're getting people who are
like i don't care i'll do anything for
money
and now they're coming in and now
they're going to start cracking skulls
and for a while it was really crazy
when the cops were pushing around
conservatives they'd give them the
benefit of the doubt like there's some
footage from dc
where the cops are shoving proud boys
and the proud boys are like thank you
officer thank you officer like
still not quite getting it until the
cops started defending protecting antifa
and now they're starting to be like hey
wait a minute we defended you
while they were calling to take your
budgets your pension and to take your
job
and now you're attacking us let me tell
you i told this story before
the story of occupy youngstown ohio i
love this story you know why
during the occupy movement you had all
these big protests across the country
okay youngstown ohio got interesting
because the fire department and the
police
joined in the protests now the
government of youngstown was very clever
you want to know how they how they shut
the protest down
they went to the cops and said we'll
give you whatever you want the cops made
ridiculous demands
they said you got it and then the cops
turned around and started arresting
everybody who protested with them
so the firefighters who had marched with
the cops all of a sudden the cops were
arresting them
in that amazing the moment they were
like we'll give you your paycheck they
were like
hot dog we're good arrest them everybody
yeah we don't need them anymore
there's a quote that comes to mind that
i kind of want to read here and it says
historically the most terrible things
war genocide and slave slavery have
resulted not from disobedience but
from obedience and when you look at
history it's a very
important telling tale of people just
following orders blindly because they
were told to do so and they did
well listen it's really really simple
what's going on right now i'll lay it
out for you some of these cops
may have been good people at some point
like i'm talking about the ones that are
arresting
innocent people the ones whether you're
left or right the ones that are shutting
down churches and businesses
but here's what happens we're we're
almost we're 10 months or so nine months
into a lockdown
where a third of small businesses in new
jersey are gone permanently
and this may maybe across the entire
country uh the yelp is intentionally
gone too i would say now
the cops are sitting there in their car
and they see a bunch of regular
americans saying
my life has been destroyed and you the
cop thinks i don't want to lose my job
man
i'll be like them starving and begging
for food and screaming
no way you're under arrest that is i
wouldn't want to look like the people
arrested in portland
no you look you you look at these these
people who have had their restaurants
shut down
whose employees have been laid off and
there's nothing left and these protests
are turning into
regular people being like you've
destroyed my life and the cop
sees that and says i never want to be in
that position
i'll take my paycheck just tell me who
like i
i will get dropped to my knees and lick
the boot of anybody but make sure
i don't end up like them that's a coward
and a traitor you know that i've been
i've lost thousands of followers even
from trump supporters and conservatives
over the years by
literally laying this out just telling
people like listen i don't i don't back
blue that doesn't back america
and you were saying this earlier before
the show tim like the constitution is
being just thrown in the trash in
multiple big blue states it's gone
you know cops have to understand i've
been saying this a lot is police
officers
it's not enough to sit here and say well
we're just doing our job you know we're
just doing our job like you you should
have been
educated you should have known and been
aware that you took a constitutional
oath
to protect and serve the people in the
context of the constitution of the
united states of america
they are getting orders down the pipe
that violate that and violate
civil rights in the united states of
america then we're not going to support
you
we're not going to support anything you
do at all my general understanding is
that
there's they swear an oath to the
constitution there's like the the police
oath or whatever
it's like doctors have like the
hippocratic oath whatever protect life
their community
yeah and the constitution of the united
states they're oath breakers
they're they're people who care not for
honor no integrity no honor
no rights of individuals it's just i
want what i deserve
i get what i want period but here's i
think it's intentional because there's
two parts of this number one
okay when i was in seattle i have i tend
to to try to get a lot of good contacts
in major police departments
obviously if you're going to be working
behind lines even incognito sometimes
you've got to make sure you're not going
to fall victim
to some of the the the intensity so do
you notify police departments before
going undercover
at times yes or contacts there even this
last time i was in dc i
noted some mpd even when i was in
portland they tried to arrest me and i
told them who i was and they let me go
meaning they're there there are some
very good officers who are just trying
to uphold the law
but what i did know is by talking to
different officers when did you notice
let's say this is specifically seattle
when did you notice things going
downhill
and i started asking this back in
january when i got a concussion
and the police did nothing when the
person assaulted me in front of them
it's a common story but
people hear all the time but the police
did nothing so i was like when did this
happen the police don't arrest someone
who uh you know assault someone in front
of them
and he goes well what happened is number
one you know bad uh
bad distribution of power where
bureaucrats have too much power that are
not directly connected to the police
department this includes
cities like portland where the police
chief is like appointed by the mayor and
the mayor shares power over the police
department
and he's thinking about weird leftist uh
radical leftist policies in a city not
how do we uphold law and order but on
top of that he goes that pushes a lot of
the cops who just want to uphold law
order out
so it creates this vacancy of like i
think last time i was in seattle they
had like 370 might have been higher than
that spots that were vacant that hadn't
been filled
and these are high paying jobs like like
60 to 80 grand which is good for people
in general now they said so what happens
is that a lot of people now are leaving
the military
and so as they leave in the military
they're like well what do i do next now
they can go to college or a quick way
they don't have to go to colleges become
a cop and the vacancies are open where
in these big cities and a lot of
ex-military are coming in
without training with civilian training
or working with these people and they're
beginning
to come in with military training and so
the exact opposite effect is happening
where they tried to keep out the extreme
people but now the the uh
police academies are accepting basically
just
soldiers and the police are becoming
more like a military than like a
civilian force
yeah but sure but even a soldier swears
enough to uphold the constitution
it's so much different they're training
in the military not that it disqualifies
them i'm just saying
when you get a department of a couple
hundred guys that are all just trained
in the military
and it's not first that they're being
introduced to combat through this police
training
it's gonna be a whole different way of
enforcing things and and every officer
has told me you could see the difference
the left has been saying that for a long
time but people like matt taibbi and
glenn greenwald specifically
who are some of the few uh leftists with
you know honor and that will call out
the censorship will call out the lies
and the smears from
you know intelligence agencies going
after the president and these are
liberal these are liberal dudes
soldiers i mean are thought to see
threats and eliminate them
police officers are supposed to quote
protect and serve that's the slogan here
what you were talking about reminds me
of this kind of meme going around right
now about how
allegedly stalin was teaching his
counselors how to rule and the story
goes that stalin
took took a chicken traumatized it rips
its feathers out
threw it naked on the floor and then
started throwing it throwing the chicken
pebbles
and walking away the chicken followed
him and allegedly stalin said quote
um you could do anything you want to the
people so long as they believe you are
the source of their survival
yes so when you were talking about that
specific story that's something you mean
you're calling them food or
uh pebbles uh yeah obviously no this
isn't this isn't a metaphor so this
really happened
yeah wow well this is the story going
around now allegedly
i haven't been able to verify it or fact
check it but this is stalin was teaching
his counselors
how much do you guys think it costs for
a gallon of milk
depending what state too much yeah like
if you're in hawaii what like five
dollars
i think in texas right now it's around
three bucks so
uh i recently went to the store and a
half gallon was four bucks and i thought
that was kind of crazy i was like is a
gallon
eight bucks and so i think it's like
it's getting up there
so so the question i had was when you
look at the arab spring one of the
issues they said as to why the
revolutions took place why they started
was because people were going hungry
they couldn't work enough to get their
food so eventually they just snapped
but if people are are like like luke is
bringing up if they're getting food
they'll take abuse they'll ignore
certain things like whatever i got my
food
it's kind of like how you get like a
lion and if you give the lion
endless amounts of food and that's
always just well fed it won't attack
smaller animals it's pointless it's like
it doesn't bother
but now with this hype with the fears of
hyperinflation and i think
like we we had a peak prosperity on
chris chris martin
chris martin's and people are spirited
yes he was talking about hyperinflation
is hitting
uh things wealthy people buy so
luxury goods land are hyperinflating
like crazy
it's going to start there and then work
its way down and that's what i was at
the store i was looking at groceries
i was talking to this dude and he said
that he
like he leaves the store with a grocery
bill to see how much he spent
hundreds of dollars and he barely fills
his cart anymore and i'm wondering if
we're just not seeing it because we're
frogs in a pot boiling but the prices
are starting to go up
and we just haven't noticed yet i
noticed when the lady scanned the half
gallon of milk at four bucks and i was
like no
really i noticed when it's not cheaper
to really eat at home than it feels like
sometimes than to eat
out like sometimes i'm even like hey how
about we eat out for lunch because it's
probably cheaper than making a nice meal
i mean i'm being serious when you go
when you go look at at steak for
instance
even at costco wholesale i mean if
you're looking at like something even
not even the best cut of meat possible
just something like a new york
strip you're still looking at about 54
bucks for a pack of
meat and you're going for steak i mean
at that price i remember just last year
before all the riots everything happened
and the shortages
the same thing was somewhere between
like 17 to 21 bucks i mean you're
talking about
if you talk about just beef or steak
that's like you know
hundreds of percent increase in price i
was just talking to
a construction company and they told me
to get ready for the next year because
raw materials about to skyrocket
and i was like why what's going on and
they're like
we're just getting ready for that big
hit where the prices just jolt way up
and so i'm looking at this news reports
you know when we were talking to chris
he was saying 66 percent
of all us dollars printed in the past 10
months mostly because i guess the latest
stimulus bill
but when we first did a segment it was
october yeah and it was 35 it was like
35.6 percent 32.6
less than that i think it was like 25.
no no uh 23.
then a month later and now let me let me
show you this
m1 money stock from st louis fed
you can just see right here the money
stock jumps it's at around
uh 4 trillion and now it's at what is
what are we at
6.6 so it it jumped up
more than 50 percent so like 50 60
percent
that's gonna have an impact people need
to realize this while china becomes the
big dog
that's right and now that they've moved
at the timeline to where china takes
over overtaking 2028 right yup yup
originally they were projecting was like
2035. now they're moving it down they're
like wow the u.s is burning to the
ground
you know i don't know i don't know if
this is connected but i was telling this
i was telling lydia this earlier at
lunch did you guys see the video of
wuhan
parting new year's eve the pool parties
this is what i saw this is what i saw
i obviously obviously you see the
hypocrisy right but
number one why is wuhan celebrating an
american holiday new year's eve
i don't even think that video was real i
think that was propaganda
propaganda 100 because all of a sudden
china's celebrating nye while
new york time uh the times square shut
down we're all on lockdown to me that
was a flex by china
flexing on america saying you guys are
all shut down while we're open
celebrating
are they trying to convince americans on
the right
that you can go out and party and look
we're doing it why can't you
well perception is reality and when we
look at china
they have they have closed themselves
off to the rest of the world and they're
arresting any journalist
that just questions their official
narrative their official line that
they're trying to get out there
recently we saw the citizen journalist
that was talking about the coronavirus
that
actually told the world about the
coronavirus she was just sent to jail
for four years right four years in jail
for citizen reporting
and there's a couple you know
possibilities here
it could be that because china knows
how this sickness how the coronavirus
originated
if they know who the patient zero is if
they know that they might be
handling this sickness the coronavirus
way better than we are and they could be
hiding that information
or it could be that they haven't handled
it and that they're just covering up
the deaths of millions of people which
they historically did before
so both of those possibilities could be
true both of them are pretty terrifying
and scary let me
i want to tell you we're gonna we're
gonna combine these stories my friends
we don't just randomly talk about china
partying and then talk about
the money supply same story first let me
show you this from cnbc
dollars sucked into downward spiral by
u.s
twin deficits from december 30th they're
saying the dollar is in a downward
spiral bitcoin skyrocketing hit what 35
000
for a bitcoin people are buying up like
crazy and there's there's concerns
i mean it's not necessarily a bad thing
but people are saying that the bitcoin
is not going to go back down there's not
going to be a correction
it's undervalued at this point because
the us dollar is being printed like
crazy
which brings me to this really strange
story which seems maybe not to be
related
chinese billionaire jack ma vanishes
what happened
quite simply they say at the bund summit
in shanghai on the 24th of october
ma criticized the lawmakers that enforce
global financial regulations
the basil accord saying they were like
an old people's club
according to the times ma a communist
party member said the basil accords are
like an old people's club
we can't use yesterday's methods to
regulate the future
the billionaire said the basil accords
framework stifled opportunities for
young people in developing nations
and that regulatory rules suppressed
innovation before the summit
and group was preparing for a 37 u.s
billion dollar initial public offering
and would have been value and would have
valued the company at more than 300
billion dollars
after the summit things changed china
cracked down on regulations
smothering ant groups ipo et cetera et
cetera i'll just put it this way the
very simple
issue here a lot of people are are
saying this is this is crazy about jack
ma
when you criticize the global financial
infrastructure and you have the power to
actually make change
bad things happen to you i can say
gaddafi saddam hussein
not for the same reasons obviously but
jack ma comes out and starts talking
smack about
financial regulators for you know global
economics and he's gone yeah
and this is not just one of the richest
people in china this is one of the
world's richest people that was
disappeared and is missing
since october he was kicked out and
edited out of his own tv show he was
edited out for many websites
and no one knows where he's been and we
have to understand china has a history
of disappearing very prominent economic
figures there's uh ren zik zang i'm
saying it
very wrong but he was a real state mogul
who criticized
china's handling of the coronavirus
there's yao
zhing hao who was an asset manager also
disappeared under mysterious
circumstances
and no one knows what happens to these
people and a lot of people need to
understand china uses
a lot of kind of mystery they they hide
a lot of information
so your kind of imagination plays the
worst fears on you and this has been a
tactic that the chinese have been using
for a very long time so are these people
that had like
shows they were media shows businesses i
mean
if you look at alibaba that's one of the
chinese trump yeah yeah
we're looking at one of the biggest
companies not just in china but the
world
and he's the head guy he criticized
their central bank he criticized
regulations because obviously if you
want a free-flowing economy
you can't have a central bank you can't
have all these regulations you can't
have the government deciding what is
best
you should let the market decide he
criticized that and because of that
uh we don't use pressure we don't know
exactly
what he's missing from his show but we
can say this we can't say this but he's
missing from public life he hasn't been
seen
since october right but the evidence
here is this
you can't say that there's some you know
global new world order or bilderberg
group that's causing
crises but you can say that when crises
hit on a global scale
very important people oftentimes can
disappear find themselves losing
everything that matters to them and the
entire world sees some sort of
structural change that seems to benefit
the wealthy
and the ruling class it seems to screw
over the middle class and then at the
end of this crisis
there seems to be new organizations that
come up let's just say like ngos or even
new banking systems or unified
trade agreements that seem to help fix
and bring it all together and
power gets centralized into people who
are not elected exactly one of the
things that china uncensored said when
they were on this show that really
sticks out to me is the fact that
it's our participation and the us
establishment
propping up china that makes them as
powerful as they are right now
and it's literally american elites that
are causing china to be as powerful on
the world stage and if it wasn't for
them
they wouldn't exist and they wouldn't be
as powerful our economy is being crushed
right now
and they say you're moving the timeline
for china's economy to overtake
ours so uh i don't think any of these
people really care you know why
a lot of them probably invested in
companies that are doing production in
china or things of that nature
probably the nike they did they do yeah
let me let me ask you guys something you
ever think about
how banking works on a global scale or
like what do you mean no
just let me so when you let's say you
got a thousand bucks in the bank right
and then you no no you write a check
to uh a friend who then cashes that in
their bank and it becomes available
immediately
did that one bank take the thousand
dollars from your account physical cash
put in a cart
wheel it down the street to the other
bank and hand it to them so that money
is now in that bank
or is it literally just a number in a
computer that could be changed
so i got a crazy story one of the
craziest things i've ever seen that made
me like
what i had a friend who was uh we went
to a bank
because he was he was negative his
account went negative and so he was like
i gotta go complain
because there was a transaction that was
doubled an accident
and that put me negative and then it
threw everything out of whack cause then
he got charged 35 bucks and then his
next deposit didn't you know get him out
of it then he got charged again and it
kept going negative
we walk into this bank and there's and
there's a guy sitting
behind his desk and he's like an older
middle-aged dude this is in chicago
and he pulls up the dude's account and i
swear i don't know what he was showing
us
maybe it was a trick maybe it wasn't
real but he shows his account as
negative like three bucks
and he just erased the negative sign and
says how does that look and then we were
like what and he was like looks good
right and he was like i guess and he was
like get out of here kid
and then he was like what then he
checked his account and he was positive
when he was negative
i don't know what that was or what went
down it was weird to me
but i will tell you one thing the next
week when we were skating downtown the
bank
was closed like they shut down that
branch so i was thinking to myself i'm
like i wonder if this dude knew he was
getting laid off
and was like i don't care and just type
numbers into his account to make the
money be there
but i'm like how do they verify that how
do they know like
is there it's the craziest thing it's
not like bitcoin when you have a
transaction and a limited amount of
something it's literally someone going
on the computer and just pressing zero
that's it that's our financial system
explained
as and of course whenever there's you
know the military-industrial complex
big pharma the medical industrial
complex coming in for their gibbs
of course that machine's turned on right
away people come in there for
you know health and human services or
something to help out the common you
know whatever
whatever the common good is or whatever
the term people or whatever people
socially want to improve
you know life no sorry the machine
doesn't work then which is absolutely
ridiculous so we're going through this
what i was thinking is like
where is so is all of our money is
basically digital has anyone really
thought about how
bitcoin has a ledger with crypto that
secures it
and banks just kind of write a number
down well you know you know what what
shocked me i think the most was
remember i was watching a documentary on
the 2008 financial crisis and i might
have the numbers a little bit wrong
but i think they said that two trillion
dollars disappeared
from the global economy they use the
phrase disappeared remember looking that
up
because i know that i think we lost like
9.8 trillion dollars overall
like home value in the world this has to
do with you know just like fluctuations
of the values of homes the money didn't
disappear this isn't changing ledgers
but like obviously they didn't burn cash
reserves or like melt down gold and just
you know turn it around
yeah you're going how do you just take
two trillion dollars when the average
person in the world makes less than like
a dollar a day
yeah where do what do you mean it
disappeared well after the 2008
uh housing crisis the federal reserve
engaged in secret bailouts where they
were literally
printing money and giving it digitally
to foreign
banks i actually confronted ben bernanke
on the
largest kind of bailout in recorded
human history that no one even talks
about
and he had a fit about it he literally
tried to rip my microphone away from me
because i asked him you know how does it
feel knowing that you committed one of
the largest bailouts and no one even
knows about it and we're talking about
you know with the t trillions of dollars
that literally go from one hand to
another hand
yes we're here now and look at the
national debt look at the price of
common
household goods of what they are now
compared to what they were
just even 50 years ago i'm i'm look man
uh i was talking to so we're looking at
like crazy farmland crazy open space in
west virginia
and i'm hearing from these agents
they're like we can't keep inventory
the moment like land pops up in west
virginia gone the market's increasing
like crazy the
the value of homes is going up outside
of new york outside of these big cities
property values starting to go up like
crazy because nobody wants to live in
these cities anymore
but it's like i was saying earlier
actually i think it was chris who was
saying this that
the things wealthy people can buy right
now are hyperinflating
because the demand for these for these
goods is
is high for several reasons one get away
from the cities too
they're getting rid of their money
they're getting rid of us dollars
they're buying gold
they're buying bitcoin like crazy why
did bitcoin
double almost triple in value in a month
now people will say oh you know you hear
from all these bitcoin deniers
where they're like it's just like it's a
scam and it's like dude
people have confidence in it retaining
its value enough to where
it was going for like 13 000
a month and a half two months ago and
now it's at thirty thousand dollars
so i'll tell you this you can look at
your bitcoin transaction history
and you can go back go back to like for
those of those of you that have bitcoin
i've had bitcoin for a long time
and someone sent me like a couple bit
like a couple dollars worth of bitcoin
a long time ago it's not worth like 200
bucks it's just you look at it that's
crazy
people are concerned i think here's what
here's what i was telling people
what what are the rich people who have
connections doing right now
they're fleeing cities they're buying up
property like crazy and they're getting
off the us dollar when cnbc says the
dollar is in a downward spiral
and bitcoin is through the roof i hope
you all are paying attention what what
we're potentially facing
so i'll put it this way you know i've
had people say to me we did a promo
uh start to start the show with the safe
and ready meals thing right this is uh
the savingreadymeals.com it is emergency
food supply
and so people always look like i got a
bunch of it just because i bought it
whatever
and they're like man do you are you
prepping like you think the end is
coming and i'm like i don't know i don't
know if i would tell people i think the
end is nigh
like the world's gonna end and we're
gonna be walking around like it's
fallout you know the video game and
you know fighting zombies or anything
like that but uh when was the last time
the u.s
printed what like trillions of dollars
like 2.6 trillion
and borrowed what five trillion more
when was the last time they they added
60 of the money supply in 10 months
they've never done that and what
historically happens when money is mass
produced and mass printed
you face hyperinflation or collapse of
the currency
and then uh you combine that with rich
people buying up land like crazy and
fleeing
to places like idaho iowa wyoming west
virginia
and you need to ask yourself why is it
the people with the money
are trying to spend their money as fast
as possible why
are you looking at this so maybe we get
everything's fine the u.s currency can't
collapse it's a petrodollar maybe
i'm not i'm not i'm i'm not going to
pretend i can i can see the future and i
know
but i just look at like here's why i
tell people
when you're when you're out and you guys
might uh might
get this when you're out in a conflict
and a riot or whatever
or when you're in a big protest and then
you see a bunch of people
then you see a bunch of people start
running in a certain direction right
when i see that i think
they must have seen something or someone
did and they're running for a reason
sometimes it's a false alarm
sometimes they run because they got
scared of a car back firing
but sometimes someone saw the national
guard or some riot cop
aiming a beanbag gun or tear gas
and so they ran i run the other door i
run perpendicular to the direction
they're running because i don't want to
be in that crowd
but i look to the people and i see where
are they running to
it's almost like when you're like a
storm is about to come you see the birds
leaving like they do in the movies
when the rich people are lighting their
money up like just getting rid of it as
fast as possible
the us is printing you know trillions of
dollars
record um like you know money money
supply going up
and we're seeing land get sold like
crazy
like don't you think at a certain point
the people who have connections that are
in the know are making the moves before
you catch on because they want you
holding the bag
or they don't want to be holding the bag
when when the when the drop comes
here's my thing okay i i'm a christian i
don't know what you guys view is on this
but i think
i'm i'm a huge believer in the end times
in bible prophecy
and i think that the antichrist is a
reality
and i think the agenda is obviously
there and it's joe biden i thought it
was hillary clinton i don't know i don't
know
who it's going to be but one thing i
will say is it's very interesting that
with the advent of the antichrist comes
alongside of
access through the mark of the beast
that gives you access
to a one world economy so it's very
interesting i'm not saying it's in the
mask
yeah they talk about a one-world economy
one world government where the end
result
of when you know the end times it
actually talks about
an economy yeah yeah what is it like
what specifically does it say though it
says that the
false prophet you could pull it up the
false prophet will cause people to take
the mark of the beast which is 666 that
will give them the ability to buy
sell and trade that will allow them to
access the economy at the time so i
think it's interesting that
we're seeing a lot of stuff with the
masks we're seeing a lot of stuff
we're also seeing specifically an mrna
vaccine a new technological advancement
with many large institutions saying you
won't be able to participate
in our economy unless you have this
vaccine so that's also another aspect of
this to kind of
and in bible prophecy that's that's the
final showdown you won't be able to
access the economy
without the mark of the beast which is
an act of worship to pretty much satan
in the flesh
yeah let's say and even from my
understanding though i don't have it up
here it also comes up in daniel and
isaiah
the whole point of biblical prophecy is
that not only will people be trading and
be given in marriage world will be like
it was but the key thing is
is that the antichrist is meant to bring
the world together into one world
government
and then he'll sit on the throne in the
temple rebuilt on the temple mount in
israel and he'll call himself god and
people will follow
and anybody who doesn't take whatever
the mark is is going to be seen as a
threat and a danger to people and they
themselves are an enemy of society
and deserve to be killed so they start
killing everyone who won't take the mark
which we don't know what that means
but but i'm but i'm just saying like
it's crazy though when you read
revelation
and it says that this is what the end
will look like and it describes how
people will be
i didn't know this revelation 13 17
that no man might buy or sell save he
had the mark of the name of the beast or
the number
of his name i didn't know that and it
says that the ten kingdoms will will
serve
under him and it specifically says this
is what's crazy the ten kingdoms of the
world whatever that means will
will rise up and he'll come above them
and there's this idea that
this is what he brings together and this
is why anybody that is
that is coming against him is coming
against the global order
and therefore they are a threat to
public safety and that's why not only
can they not buy sell and trade
but eventually they get beheaded and
they start beheading people who
who will not take the mark and that's
like they'll kill you it's an
act of worship to the antichrist being
your god that's why you have to take
it this is why a lot of right-wing
christians have always been against the
kind of larger term
new world order and when you look at
them there's always been a congregation
of
individuals who are church-going that
usually do speak about this
you know in in in in a very large extent
so what you're saying makes absolutely
sense from what i've been hearing for
you know since the 90s people were
talking about this
and more and more when you look at
current events i mean you can make many
different correlations you could have
many different understandings but
i think what everyone here is saying is
that these are definitely
interesting times to say the least and
definitely times that will
test everyone in many important
instances i mean you got to think about
it when you read like the bible and you
look at bible prophecy
satan himself literally wants to be god
right
when you read certain passages of
lucifer's fall he wanted to be god he
wanted to ascend above god he wanted to
be worshiped as god
himself so when you take a look at the
entire scope of scripture through the
old testament and the new testament
you'll see lucifer and satan himself
literally mirroring what god has done or
what god will do
so he will declare himself to be god in
the temple in israel because he wants to
be worshipped as god
and the whole tie with the economy with
the one world religion and the one world
economy taking the mark of the beast
is in the old testament you would see
that god instructed the jews he would
instruct them to
write bible verses on their on their
arms or on their foreheads and still to
this day you see hassanic jews
orthodox jews that still put bible
verses on their foreheads or even on
their arms they walk around with that
in the end lucifer is going to use the
antichrist to do the exact same thing
to give people access to the economy but
what's the real tie there
the real tie is if you get humanity to
believe
that there is no hope and there's only
one hope that can
cause you to survive which is the
economy i mean throughout all human
history
throughout all religions world religions
doesn't matter whether you're muslim
whether you're buddhist it doesn't
matter
we all need to survive and the economy
keeps us afloat
so in the end times god is literally the
provider of all humanity that's my
belief that's what that's that's what i
i believe he's my provider he's he's my
all in all right
but lucifer wants to be that as well and
if he can take everything that he has
from you
especially the way that you got it you
will bow your knee to whomever will give
it back to you
well i don't know a whole lot about all
that revelation stuff but i can say
it's true people don't know how to
survive outside of the current system so
a lot of the left they don't understand
what economy means they have this meme
oh no the economy it's like bro the
economy means the system by which
goods and services are brought to the
people who need them
it means household management you're
hungry the economy is a reference to the
system of how that food is grown
produced sent to the store so that you
can buy it or so that the government can
give it to you
even if the government so this is what
they don't understand communism
has an economy it's called the command
economy this household management of a
country is an authoritarian communist
system it doesn't work very well as
we've seen throughout history
but it literally is an economy so many
people i ask you this
how many people who live in any of these
big cities know how to even grow
food like we saw with the larp farm at
the chazz the
the autonomous zone in seattle it was
beautiful it kind of
we just a throwback it was so the my
favorite part about that
that garden was that for a while they
had a garden for black people
only and then it switched to people of
color and the worst part was is that
that was the only garden that wasn't
growing food
and no one could figure out if the
people weren't planting the food
or if white people were too afraid to
plant because it was all white people
tending the gardens the
farm was garbage they didn't understand
anything about basic farming at all they
put potted plants in the dirt
they threw a cart yeah they threw
cardboard down through dirt on it and
then put potted plants in it
did did you even look something up on
google
bro if you don't know how to farm you
can't farm so look i don't expect
anybody even here to know how can you
farm seriously we we've grown our own
food because people have gardens so a
lot of people understand like you know
general gardening but farming is a whole
other other issue
you know like when do you rotate crops
how do you preserve the land when do you
fallow or things like that
farming requires farmers who know what
they're doing and can tell you how it's
done
these people in cities won't survive
without the economy
i mean look at someone getting the food
to them did you see people's responses
to lack of toilet paper did you see
people's responses it's still happening
right now
though i mean realistically speaking
though and i'll say this like i actually
so i was i was totally
i've never bulk bought anything i i have
this idea that
god provides for me and i don't need to
worry or fear
but i'll tell you this there was one
moment where because i'll tell you we
got it when i was living in l.a we have
good mexican food and i'll tell you it's
good going in the other side's another
story
and you need toilet paper there are
those moments and i'm you know i'm newly
married and i'm in my house
and i'm like all right god will provide
i know this sounds so ridiculous before
2020
and i start noticing there's like four
toilet paper rolls left
then three toilet paper rolls left i'm
going
okay okay god provide and
and i was like i was like okay there was
like this one morning it was like 6 am i
like woke up out of my sleep i was like
i gotta go wait in line somewhere to get
toilet paper and so like i went to go to
target
i waited in line it opened no toilet
paper even waiting in line for an hour
so then we're rationing toilet paper
like little pieces and we're trying to
eat like non-high-fiber foods and stuff
and it got to the point where i ended up
waiting in a two and a half hour line
in costco just to get a pack of toilet
paper
and i remember thinking this entire
system
is so much more fragile than i could
have ever hoped for or imagined
that i just took a day off of work to be
able to wipe my butt but hold on
at what point in a situation like that
would you just grab a towel rip a piece
off
and then be like i guess we're doing it
the old fast we were a date we were a
day
away we were a day away of just planning
like taking some leaves off the tree i
swear i think we're
close okay i got something to confess i
got something to confess okay oh no all
right all right i literally
my okay my wife is watching and she's
probably freaking dying right now
[Laughter]
i literally went to this like super
ghetto mexican supermarket
because there was no toilet paper in
california wherever we went
and i literally bought like five packs
of like a hundred packs of napkins this
toilet paper
really should have just sponges i just
want to confess that on record
that i listen i bought out napkins at a
ghetto supermarket
think about think about the response
people had to this right
instead of being like well they're out
of toilet paper
what can we do to solve this problem
they're just like i'm gonna go wait in
line for several hours you guys i'm
gonna go wait in line and just
eventually someone will give me toilet
paper i guess have you been to la it's
not like there's a lot of trees there
anyways to
cut down and plant all my japanese
friends are laughing at all of you guys
right right now well they have they have
their fancy toys yeah yeah they got the
fancy toilets
brazilians brazil i went to brazil once
this is a funny story i went to the
hotel
and the bathroom has like a concave
floor with a drain in the middle
and there was a hose next to the toilet
no this is
brazil most of the world does this yeah
most of the world and so i was at i was
at an office for like a
company and that was their bathroom and
i was like like
do i just spray and then it goes down
the drain like what is this and when i
came out i was like man i'm from america
we don't have that and she was like
you don't have that and i was like yeah
like the hose and she goes
how do you clean yourself and i was like
what do you mean you toilet paper and
she goes
that doesn't clean anything and i was
like oh that's a good point i use i use
wet honestly though i'll tell you this
is this is a serious protein
wait no this is a serious pro tip that
my doctor even told me
they make like flushable antiseptic like
wet
wipes that actually clean in america and
they're if you can't find toilet paper
usually you can go to the section the
toddler section or you can find it in
the adult section
they're flushable like baby wipes and
they're actually clean you use less of
them so if you're trying to ration paper
or you're in a place where they don't
have a lot of toilet paper
check the flushable wipes and they're
often in stock the most important
podcast in the world thank you ladies
and gentlemen
share this podcast if you like learning
about proper toilet paper
hold on another thing people need to
realize is that
we as americans are extremely spoiled
and after just traveling the world i
mean most people just use
natural squatty potties as a way to
relieve themselves
no one here at this house by the way
uses a squatty potty i'm disgusted
i'm no i disagree with you but another
thing to really kind of think here
is that we are not resilient a lot of
people in in like places like mexico
that that have went through economic
collapses people who have to wait
long lines just to get their money just
to get their bi-weekly bi-monthly
paycheck
they are resilient they are prepared for
everything the city slickers
the flip-flop latte drinking starbucks
loving yuppies they're not ready for
anything
and when time really comes to a head and
they have to deal with the realities of
a country
27 trillion dollars in debt that still
gives out
billions of dollars in foreign aid when
they have to deal with the larger
ramifications of these politicians
selling them
down the river they're going to have a
very rude awakening and when people
panic when people freak out
that's going to be really a true test of
anyone in any major city and it's one of
the reasons i left new york city and i'm
never coming back
the u.s federal debt to gdp ratio was at
130.47 percent
130 in 2000 was at 59 percent
in 1980's at 34. thanks donald trump
that's what rand paul was warning rand
paul remember the big speech on the
stimulus package the stimulus but that's
why dude
we we can't afford stuff like that right
now especially giving i mean no
it's nothing new that we give billions
of dollars of foreign aid away but it's
like in the midst of this
pandemic all of a sudden we're giving
billions of dollars to pakistan for
gender studies or yeah but it's not even
aid it's it's speed boats for sri lanka
they call it yeah it's 1.3
what is it it's a huge exorbitant amount
not just to israel but other countries
like egypt sudan
there's so many of these countries just
getting handouts and where does this
money go it usually doesn't go towards
even that country it goes towards the
middle person
the bureaucrat standing in the way that
stifles it in for themselves
their friends their special interests
they get the money and that's why
we didn't have the 2 000 stimulus check
that's why we had
gender studies in pakistan so you have
right now
27 trillion dollars in debt and then
people will ask me tim do you think
things are gonna get really bad
i'm not gonna tell yes or no i'm just
gonna say people with connections are
buying up land like crazy and dumping
dollars for things like bitcoin
and we are 27 trillion dollars in debt
while our government just
gave away billions of dollars to other
countries
so let me tell you something think about
that friend you have right
and he lives in an apartment he hasn't
paid his rent and then he gets his rent
money and he says yeah but you know
we're gonna go out to the bar
or or it goes on only fans and gives it
to lula
all right lula's getting my money that's
literally the government the government
is
the simp that is simping to china i had
a whole huge analogy to this it's kind
of a
adult so i'm not going to say it here
but literally they they take the money
you're supposed to pay rent together
he goes on only fans spends all of it
does fetanol from china
afghanistan um
every time a stimulus package comes out
if it's six hundred dollars or if it's
twelve hundred dollars
you'll see like all these tvs in walmart
that are like
ten dollars like less than your stimulus
and then
i just i hate to say this but i really
think it's a lot of like uneducated
people that don't even pick up on stuff
like that
because they know they'll go spend their
money at these massive corporate
entities
like walmart just to give them the upper
edge and give them the millions and
billions of dollars
well the mom-and-pop shops they they
suffer and they die and i think that's
by design
you've got the best democrat campaign
slogan for georgia right now
vote for the democrats in georgia you're
gonna get two thousand dollars
because the mitch mcconnell blocked it
and they're not gonna they're not gonna
do it but the democrats are like we
wanna we want to
so if the democrats win you're getting
paid so there were a lot of people that
were
that didn't care about politics but they
were like yo my boy trump just gave us
you know cash awesome trump gets his
name on the checks or whatever
that's big giving people money you'll
get votes so the government feels like
like alcohol in 2021 it's like
oh your life's depressed because you've
been getting drunk too often
wasting your money and sleeping around
how about we numb that out with a couple
more shots of vodka tonight and then
you'll forget about your problems like
we're going to give you more government
to fix your government problems from
2020.
that's the cure is just giving you your
way out we're going to keep bending you
over and that's
how i feel digging your way out of a
hole it reminds me of the simpsons where
they they're looking for treasure or
something and they dig 20 feet down and
they're like
uh how do we get out and homer's like
we'll dig our way out and just keep
digging
well i think i think what's really
literally what's really cool about all
this though is that
where i kind of almost get upset
sometimes at certain people on the right
wing or the libertarian movement that
sort of condemn
all these new people sort of waking up
and breaking out of the city slick life
break
waking up out of this democrat life they
keep saying oh they're moving to
republican states they're changing all
of our states they're moving in that
place
but according to greg abbott he said we
just did some studies in texas
uh that were looking at the way that
that voters changed their vote when they
moved
and actually 58 of californians who were
coming from california to texas
were voting republican as opposed to
what's being pushed as the narrative
that californians are switching the
state to being blue
and so what we're seeing is that
actually like me as someone from los
angeles i always love it like
people are like oh you talk funny oh
your pants are too tight you're not a
real conservative you're not a real this
or that i go i never said i'm like a
super conservative i'm come from
hollywood california like i don't
i'm not i'm waking up out of this going
holy crap
i can't if i'm gonna get married like i
got married and within months i told my
wife i was like
i know this doesn't make sense
financially i know this i know you're
not gonna make sense to my family my mom
was in the middle of dying by the way
she died three months after i left
like you don't leave your mom dying i go
as the lockdowns came we've got to get
out of here like we've got to leave this
state
because i don't know what's going to
happen but it's not going to be good and
look as we left last
june it's only gotten it's digressed in
california well you brought up a very
important point when you have to work
for what you have you automatically
become a conservative
and when a lot of these people move out
of the big cities and they move
towards the suburban areas they have to
work for
everything they got there's a there's an
interesting noise that's a helicopter
national guard yeah maybe they're coming
for you tim i told you no no
they're flying to dc yeah oh really
there's a helicopter
guys we can hear it in studio just so
but we're in the middle of nowhere so
usually when there's a helicopter going
by we're like oh what's going on with
this
yeah a few of them not just one i hear
them right yeah it was a bunch actually
it was like i'm like is this getting
louder
it's better than the jets we have i'm
right over the jet flying in texas so
like i'll be in the middle of a show
recording and they're like wonderful
so what you're saying is you're saying
that texas is becoming more red is that
what you're saying i'm saying that the
studies show that it's not the
californians changing which i mean
that's why everyone giving all these
people just waking up
a hard time i think a lot of people if
you actually look at the studies and the
trends
not a bunch of people complaining shows
like this
are working to wake people up where you
watch tim and it's not like tim's a
right wing nut job it's like in fact you
probably piss a lot of right-wing people
off
oh they're so mad at me right and it's
my point being is it is that you can sit
here and you can talk to someone like
vosh
who a lot of right-wing people hate then
you can talk to someone like myself or
or drew or whatever jones well that's
even yeah i invited
i i asked to come back with jones but he
could he didn't want to do it he was
worried about covid
and that's that's like a real left thing
they're super worried about covet
conservatives believe that they really
aren't
you know so i've actually reached out to
a bunch of leftists like you know we'll
have jones on you can come on
and for the most part they're just like
but covet you know i don't want to do it
and they're like that's a legitimate
reason they there's no point in arguing
i'm like okay you know whatever
but here i'll tell you what i think i
think you know we're seeing a lot of
people move out of big cities
the people this in california is trying
to recall newsom right
but the people they're i think they're
gonna have a hard time with it they're
doing well we'll see how it plays out
but the people who don't like newsome
leave they go move to texas they go move
to colorado
so what happens when the more
conservative people will up and go
and the people who are okay with newsm
stay
california becomes bluer and
less more apathetic i guess if you're
gonna sit there and let news um do
whatever he wants and do nothing about
it
apathy for sure so then the red states
are gonna become more entrenched
ideologically
in red the blue states become more
entrenched ideologically
ideologically in low information
apathetic tribalist
and then what happens we're already
countries split down the middle
do the red states have a resurgence and
the republicans start winning again or
do red and blue states start
pointing things at each other and then
swinging things at each other
i think i think a lot of people are
probably
blue without even knowing it what do i
mean by that i think there's a lot of
people that are defaulting
they're not they're not politically
engaged they're not into economics they
don't even understand
like the damage of a massive stimulus
but i was like go just give me my 600
bucks even though we're going to be
trillions of dollars in debt why
because it hasn't affected them
personally yet and i think a lot of
people are waking up to the reality that
their lives are being affected by these
policies and big blue states
and they're leaving these states because
it's affecting them
but are they really changing to not vote
the same way in these other states i was
talking about this with lydia earlier
it's like i think a lot of people
they recognize that bad things are
happening and it affects them
but they leave the states without
understanding why it happened in the
first place
so they still vote the same way because
of hollywood or the music industry they
see
people like jay-z or freaking cardi b up
there twerking with bernie sanders and
it's like oh well you should vote for
the democrats because
cardi b said so and it's like nothing
changes
because there's no education involved
does that make any sense
like people understand that is wrong and
they leave without understanding why and
then they just vote the same
but then you have uh so so i think i i
one of the things i say about democrats
is that they rely on
solely almost exclusively on low
information voters
easily evidenced by the fact that they
try to lower the voting age to 16 or
they've advocated for it
and that they get a lot of younger
voters clearly these are people who
haven't had
serious work experience many of them
haven't even paid taxes a lot of these
kids who graduate college and then
tend to vote democrat haven't worked a
job or they may have worked some job
but they don't really understand what it
means to run a business and pay taxes
and to pay employees and pay benefits
and all that
so they vote based on the on on their
interest and it's very simple
if you spend your life in an
institutionalized learning facility
where everything is provided for you and
you follow the rules of the authority
what are you going to vote for
institutionalization
the everything being provided from uh to
you by the authority
and following the authority as you know
verbatim as they say
conservatives and uh non-college
educated people are people who they
they mock and they'll insult aha you're
a working class you don't go to school
you're so dumb
you know democrats are smarter it's like
or actually conservatives tend to be
people who
are self-reliant they'll go out work for
themselves they'll get a job they'll pay
taxes they'll start a business
they don't go to college that means they
have to support themselves somehow
so they're not in institutionalized
learning facilities where the authority
is telling them what to do and providing
for them
that creates a clear distinction as the
generations get older and enter the
voting population right but i think
there's there's more people somewhere in
the middle and
i think there's this whole class of
people developing and here's what i mean
is like the far left crazy people are
saying one thing like
you know there's no gender and you know
your sexuality is fluid and your you
know your kids ate but they know they're
you know if they want to get a sex
change you should listen to them and
take their advice even though
you know they have a bedtime somehow
they can decide their entire hormonal
future
i mean there's these people and i think
most people see that and they kind of
reject that because
for their own families they're like i
don't really want that for them but then
there's this like weird
similarity on the right wing too that
always asks what are you conserving
what are you conserving as if
everybody's this like all puritan
conservative
that wants this christian dumb in
america like as if that's really what
everyone in america wants
but i think most people are in this
point where they're just in the culture
and it's starting to get so extreme
and it's starting to get so in your face
where it's like they're naturally like
default blue but they're going
dude now you're starting to get into
weird like kid stuff and you're starting
to push like like we saw recently cardi
b won't even let her own kids watch her
music video she pushed her kids out of
the room when it was on tv
wow and you start you start to see like
that's what i'm saying
you go you go from you go from
suggestive music to songs like
[ __ ] that even if you're a sexualized
person and you're expressive you're
going
that doesn't need to be on tv and i
think people are starting to get sick of
it and going
there's got to be something where we're
just getting back to like setting some
standard of morality some standard of
morals that we can agree on
a lot of the big tech executives don't
even let their kids use social media one
of the one of the best compliments i got
for my song will of the people
was someone just posting the lyrics to
[ __ ] and then posting the lyrics to my
song
and they were that was that was the
point they were making like this is the
popular song with the millions of views
that everyone's talking about [ __ ]
and they were like my song which has
like 700 000 and it's like very serious
about revolutions and like you know
in politics it doesn't get it and i've
known that my whole life i've always
listened to punk music and it's never
been the most popular
and you know most listened to crazy
thing is
you know we were listening we we went
for a drive recently and we were
listening to a bunch of you know 670s
music and stuff like that
and there are some meaningful songs put
out by like classic rock bands
but then you look at the stuff that has
a billion views
a billion listens today and it's like
you've got these songs like men
probably the easiest and most iconic is
fortunate sun by korean's clearwater
revival
right you know that song fortunate son
it's this it's the vietnam song
basically
every movie about vietnam or video game
it's like they play fortunate son
it's a song about he's like you know it
ain't me i'm not no senator's son
talking about the privileged people and
the powerful connections political
elites and those with money and how they
you know can get what they want they can
avoid what they want they don't got to
pay taxes and things like that
you have these meaningful songs that got
a ton of list you know ton of downloads
and then you pull up spotify and you're
like what's getting the views and it's
like
you know whatever it's like i mean if
people like it people can buy it welcome
to capitalism but
there's like there's there's meaning
being stripped out of our arts
you know and it's becoming very just dry
and generic and basin
and uh you know i think it's it's it's
there's gonna be a culture collapse of
some sort
because we're whittling down to the
lowest common denominator to try and
like movies is a good example there was
a period where and
up until the movies were destroyed by
the lakovic lockdowns
blockbusters it's just mindless
explosions and
shrapnel like michael bay movies yeah
but the reason you know why those do
well is because it transcends language
so anybody around the world could you
could just watch you know optimus prime
transcends iq well another thing to
realize a lot of our entertainment
whether it's
art music movies has been hijacked has
been used as a way to push political
ideas
rather than to entertain its use to
program individuals
to believe certain things to have a you
know a certain ideology to have a
favorable view of institutions like
the cia or establishment institutions or
democratic institutions they're made to
look favorable and
and when you look at entertainment it's
it's not there for your viewing
enjoyment it's there to make you think a
certain way
and it's been weaponized to a degree
that's extremely dangerous in my opinion
to a certain degree i think they're
trying to make money but uh speaking of
the fbi
and you know the fbi has that that tv
show about the fbi agents the x-files
and it's about aliens a harvard
professor says alien technology
that's a great segment very smooth to
complement you on that one yeah it was
so good i'm
i'm so good at podcasting uh we got this
crazy story it's it's so
you know uh and then we'll we'll go to
superjets after this but check out the
story this is this is crazy i really
want to talk about this
harvard professor says alien technology
visited our solar system in 2017.
he also says they're coming back in his
upcoming book extraterrestrial the first
kind of intelligent life beyond earth
theoretical physicist avi loeb lays out
his theory about a peculiar shaped
object that has entered our solar system
several years ago
the intersection the inner stellar
object named
um was first observed through the pan
stars telescope in hawaii's haleakala
observatory in 2017. researchers
observed that it passed through the uh
ecliptic plane on this on september 6
from the direction of vega
a star in the lira constellation that is
about 25 light years away from our
planet
just three days later um hawaiian for
scout
began accelerating toward the sun before
it eventually came closer to earth on
october 7th
moving swiftly towards the constellation
pegasus and the blackness beyond
some scientists claimed um which is
believed to be the first interstellar
object detected in our solar system
was simply another comet however loeb
the chairman of the heart of harvard
university's astronomy department
dismisses that assumption
and as it relies too much on the
familiar what would happen if a caveman
saw a cellophone
you wondered he's seen rocks all his
life he would have thought it was just a
shiny rock
loeb says that there are two big details
that suggest um
wasn't just a comet but a piece of alien
technology
the first detail is the object's
dimensions as it was determined to be
five to ten times longer than it was
wide
loeb argues the cigar-like shape isn't
typical for natural space object
but the theoretical physicist lays the
biggest detail that supports his theory
is the movement the excess push away
from the sun
that was the thing that broke the
camel's back loeb explains the sun's
gravitational force would cause a
natural object to move faster
as it approaches and eventually push the
object back causing it to move slower as
it moves away
low points out that this didn't occur
with um which accelerated slightly
but to a highly statistically
significant extent
if we are not alone are we the smartest
kids on the block he asks
if there was a species that eliminated
itself through war or changing the
climate
we can get our we can get our act
together before uh and behave better
instead we are wasting a lot of
resources on earth fighting each other
and other negative things that are a big
waste
he said also for coming back this is not
the first
story we got this year about aliens
being real and coming to earth and now
the head of
harvard's astra was astronomy department
yeah has said
yeah aliens are real so uh we talked we
talked about revelations a little bit
but what if it's uh
what if aliens are coming well some
religious people believe
those are demonic entities some
conspiracy theorists believe otherwise
some people say it's advanced technology
but it really does kind of feel like
they're prepping us for something
i mean we had that head of the israeli
space program we had these recent new
revelations we have
the event that just happened in hawaii
we have the disclosure which is supposed
to happen
in about a hundred and eighty days
that's in the coveted relief bill we'll
clarify that yeah
somehow in the covid the kobet omnibus
the spending bill
was uh the intelligence authorization
act which included
from the time of passing the bill 180
days the pentagon must release all their
information on ufos
so they've been slow rolling this we
just saw a crazy ufo in west virginia we
did a segment about it it looked nuts
people saying it was a flaming ufo
crashing earth or something
but uh i don't know everybody's been
speculating aliens are coming
what do you guys think i think i think
it's a mixture
i think uh if you take a look at world
war ii with roswell
you know coming out of that how nasa
came out you know there definitely was
like this technological boom in
advancement
because the nazis were obviously
involved with like black magic and adolf
hitler was obsessed with that like
obtaining
even the scientists like crazy nazi
scientists that were obsessed with
you know communicating with off-world
entities or whatever they called them
some people believe they're demons in
order to obtain like crazy scientific no
like knowledge and astrophysics and all
these things a lot of people believe
that's how the atom bomb came
into reality but americans got to at
first but
i think it is interesting how there's
always this connection
with technology and like off-world
entities
and if you take a look at from a
biblical perspective like you said i
mean the bible does make it very clear
that you know we wrestle not against
flesh and blood but against spiritual
hosts of wickedness and principalities
and powers but
i just want to point out how there
always is
i'll tell you this let's get let's have
a little bible study
the number one thing that i believe when
you take a look at the garden of eden
where eve was deceived what was the one
thing that he tempted her with
one thing was that she would have some
kind of super knowledge
there's always some kind of temptation
with an expert knowledge or
a knowledge that goes further or wisdom
that takes you beyond
like dmt exactly and that's what that's
what i'm that's what i'm saying is like
they're always
whenever there's ufos involved or some
kind of spiritual entities involved
there's always this
offer of like an advanced knowledge and
then an advancement in technology and i
think
i don't have you guys seen the bob lazar
documentary on netflix oh yeah right
so i definitely think there is some kind
of technological advancement i mean
have you guys seen like throughout
trump's presidency he'll come out and
say
if you guys he'll threaten nations he'll
be like if you guys keep doing this you
guys are gonna see like
you know rain and fire like the world
has never seen before i definitely and
then the space force came
right i definitely think we have
something that other
nations don't know what it is but where
that knowledge came from
i personally believe is supernatural can
we talk about trolls in like
what supernatural is in aliens or i
believe demonic beings can we talk about
can we talk about that you said with dmt
and i don't want to get like too
druggy here but but but like one thing
that's interesting is like i didn't
become
a christian till i was like 19 and i'm
still learning a lot uh
but one thing i can say is i was
agnostic before then as agnostic as a
teenager could be
but i rejected a lot of spiritual things
my my background is in science i went to
university and that i've always been
a man about like you know the physical
and what you can measure and the methods
that go
into that something that science no
longer is um
but i remember that one interesting
thing that that i didn't expect to was
to kind of get into experimenting with
drugs
growing up and you know i remember doing
drugs like ecstasy or smoking pot and
those were fun
but i remember i remember the first time
that i did i did mushrooms
uh you know i was younger and i remember
there was nothing like that that i'd
ever done in my life and the psilocybin
and that feeling
i every drug that i had consumed every
substance kind of
numbed or altered reality but i had
never felt like
i wasn't myself before living in a new
world until i had taken mushrooms
and i think trying a bunch of you know
psychedelics in those years like lsd
even like
five and meow dipped and all those
experimental ones that were coming out
cb um i think there was one time where i
just took way too many mushrooms you
know like just
too many where you've been there done
that yeah there's too many
and uh like i remember having like a
mental break
like a mental breakdown like i didn't
believe in spirits or anything but
no lie i went into my friend's bathroom
way to do this your parents are asleep
you're in the living room you take a
bunch of mushrooms wise decision
and a total 16 year old wisdom there
guys i remember like i went into the
restroom and this like
this being appeared and was telling me
to stick my head into the toilet and
drown myself
and like to kill myself and i felt like
the only way to escape what was going on
was to die and as much as it might just
sound like it was like a bad trip
i felt for a moment like real in that
moment and i felt like i woke up
and these i looked at the being in this
restroom and i can remember that it's
like a long restroom
and it was like a dark like a like a
dark force
and i remember that i had never felt so
oppressed and you know for years after
that instance i struggled with suicide
i was heavily depressed but i wasn't on
mushrooms anymore
and i started to like wake up to like
the fact that there might be something
else out there
because why is it that i'm no longer
high but these feelings that i first
experienced while
in that toilet you know are staying with
me
and i think that there's some validity
to the fact that
i think that spirits are real i think
that there is something that is that is
genuinely real and out there i know a
lot of people say it's not true
that it's just a trick of the mind or a
hallucination but the reality speaking
is when you talk about people's trips on
on hallucinogens why do they all see the
same things
you know why is this not an uncommon
experience where people see dark forces
the devil
i mean but coming into this with aliens
it's like i just we're all human
no well it depends it's not all unison
it's not all the same but some people
have positive effects on people i had
i had positive effects mostly i'm just
saying but when you come down to this i
started like
realizing there could be more and i
think that i had a genuine conversion
experience while i was sober
when i was 19 i was on the toilet i'm
not now i'm joking i was on the toilet
and i was writing this book why grace
changes everything not trying to become
a christian
not trying to like it wasn't like in
some like ten revival meeting it wasn't
emotional
and then i had just like something
clicked where like i realized that all
the pain that i felt the depression
everything
could be forgiven in a moment you can
say that i was you know that it was fake
but it was real to me
that i felt something shift in my mind
and my heart that i can't ever deny
where i began to become aware that god
was real he was in my life and i've
never been the same
and so sometimes i wonder the people
that doubt that there's something else
out there maybe it's just they haven't
experienced anything real
or they've been around so many frauds
who are trying to you know sell
something to them or like
you know they they're just basing off of
a hallucination that that's why they
don't believe i think there's like a
split in that
i'm i've met people who have told me
that uh
they've communicated with other beings
or something like that like i had one
guy who told me that he was a drug
addict
he was wasting his life and then one day
he was in the woods and he felt a voice
inside of him coming out asking him what
are you doing why are you doing this
and that was a profound spiritual
experience where he became
very very christian and then turned his
life around got off drugs
started working and he was just like
some punk rock dude he kept to
you know his love of punk rock but he
opened a business and he just totally
got away from drugs
and he was like i know you won't believe
me when i say that it happened
but it doesn't matter it happened to me
it's my experience i can tell you what i
experienced and it's your choice if you
want to believe it or not
and he was like and i understand most
people hear that are going to say that's
crazy there's no way that happened
he's like but i'm telling you a voice
came from the center of my being telling
me this
and i was like i mean i believe you but
there's two ways to explain it you had a
spiritual response
because uh another worldly being was
telling you you're destroying your life
or
you took too many drugs either way it
helped you so
it's a positive thing i think you know
just kind of roll with it and i'm i'm
not going to come out right on your
parade
and be like no you're wrong you're crazy
i'm going to be like hey man you're
doing really well for yourself you've
turned things around
whatever it was it worked and it helped
you yeah i think we also need to realize
that everything is
energy we're very energetic and to think
that it's only in the dimensions that we
see it under
it's kind of naive because there's a lot
more happening that we don't even
perceive
see or feel and there's even a lot of
theories out there and even official
scientific studies that talked about
how it could have been things like
psychedelics like mushrooms that have
propelled
civilizations that might have actually
started religions
that might have actually uh i don't know
about that one
do you have a specific reference that
i'm saying about people doing drugs
going crazy and then
well it depends well we have meth which
is you know it depends what you also
see as a drug because again people see
psychedelics
in in a scientific term not just as you
know a drug that you take for fun
but there also have been a lot of
medical studies recently that correlate
a lot of significance when it comes to
brain development and dealing with
issues like ptsd and depression
that have been very profound and very
important when it comes to this kind of
psychedelic space which kind of
according to many people merges this
physical and spiritual world and lets
people see this
veil whether good or not and i think
it's i and i think personally my own
personal opinion there is something way
bigger
there is something greater there are
entities that are good there are
entities that are bad and i think
i i think that's something that i
personally believe positive and negative
like that's one thing that i've always
questioned and maybe you can help me
with this
when you see people that claim to have
experiences with spiritual beings taking
aside the totally kooky people who
you're just going you're grifting you're
trying to get money or you're selling me
something let's take
genuine experiences whether it's on
ayahuasca or it's like a
christian experience or even some sort
of like a buddhist experience let's take
the spiritual
usually it's like kind of like the
extreme where it's like some i
encountered some being and it either
really freaked me the heck out and it
put me into a downward spiral or a
my whole life changed for the positive
it's not just like yo so i was walking
down this
being was like i'm carl how do you like
mexican candy and i was like yeah this
stuff's pretty salty but good and we
went our ways it's always like
some really extreme reaction and their
life changes
permanently everyone says my life
changed where's the where's the being
who appears and says
dude you're listening to the beatles
again that's overrated dude
zeppelin but you brought it way better
you brought up an important thing the
kind of extremes
of it and because of that a lot of
people paint these things as really good
or really bad
and we need to find the middle ground
here because you could have an
experience that could be either or and
you need to understand them not just
label them and blame them
for for whatever is going on i have a
story
i was a youth pastor for about like five
years and i was doing like you know
vocational ministry
elijah could relate to this too is i
remember this one time
i was working on a bible study to teach
on this particular night
and uh i had it all laid out you know i
spent all night studying throughout the
night because i like to study throughout
the night you know
and uh i was up until maybe like four in
the morning and then the next morning
when i woke up i had to walk down the
street
in order to go pick up one of the cars
that was getting worked on at a mechanic
shop right
and uh i remember walking down the
street
and this random homeless guy just comes
out of nowhere that i've never seen
before never met before in my entire
life
and he walks up straight up to me and
he's like
so you believe in jesus this random guy
and i'm like yeah and he starts to say
why why why are you going to go and do
what you're going to do tomorrow night
because we were going to give a bible
study we were going to feed people like
free tacos this and that
and he's like why are you going to go
there tomorrow night and do all those
nice things for those people
why are you going to feed them why are
you going to be good to them you think
you think that
that that god really cares about that
stuff and i'm like okay
and then out of nowhere he starts to
just straight up he recited
my almost my entire bible study
entire bible study to my face everything
i was going to teach on
that following day starts blaspheming
the teaching
as if the guy was in my room the night
before watching me study
the entire night long and when you take
a look at demonic
you know uh entities and the way that
they interact with people in the
scripture
is they always blaspheme christ and they
blaspheme
anything that has anything to do with
christ and a lot of people don't
understand that you know
in distant religions they'll call them
watchers or or they'll call them you
know the ones that are always listening
in but
people need to realize that whatever
your interpretation is
of it is why does it always have to
blaspheme god or blaspheme christ
and i kind of want people to just think
about that that are listening to this
right now
because i find it interesting those and
i could tell you guys some crazy stories
dude we've had kids in the ministry
12 year old 12 year old little kids
demon possessed out of their minds
eyes pitch black literally eyes pitched
like 12 year old little kid
about maybe 92 pounds 95 pounds
literally physically lifting up like
pastors
that probably weigh like two hundred and
thirty fifty possessed
kids possessed kids speaking i've seen
people possess too i didn't believe
until i saw it
yeah i'm dead serious this kid was like
12 years old was speaking in a grown
man's voice
speaking in spanish perfect spanish
wasn't even hispanic
perfect spanish you saw that happen yeah
they were doing this this kid was in my
youth group
crazy demon possessed out of his mind
most americans believe in angels and
demons this is what i think
i think like as we talked about i need
to see evidence man there's what i'm
saying there's there's a doubt in a lot
of people
let's go to haters but a lot of people a
lot of people believe in this
and i think what's happened is is that
when you go to when you go down to like
some people could call it mental illness
but we've really got to ask ourselves
with the alien question
you know it's so funny that like
christians always like you know oh
there's no aliens
but then they're telling everyone to
believe in angels and demons and then
you have these people who are like god's
not real there's no angels and demons
and they're like but there's aliens on
other planets it's like well it's all
really shows something in
it's interesting in the human condition
and brain is that there's something
in us whether it's from conditioning or
something in nature
to where we like feel like there's
something else out there a lot of
america
more i think it's more americans than
not believe in this and so it's just an
interesting
thing to me is that these stories come
out the reason why they're even they're
publishing them is because they get
clicked on
right and it's just like but we can't
prove them per se unless you were like
maybe there with him
specifically so it's like i don't know
what we can do here it's trust i
remember when i was uh when i was like
19
i was talking to this religious guy so i
grew up catholic and then i left when i
was a kid
yeah you didn't know that no i didn't
know that either yeah yeah yeah catholic
school
and then uh but i once was a teenager
it was like out the window really really
atheist
then i met a guy and he asked me he was
like
you know we were talking about religion
and then he said how do you know you're
breathing
what are you breathing right now and i
was like air and he's like yeah yeah but
like what is it and i was like
combination of gases carbon dioxide
nitrogen oxygen mostly nitrogen
he's like oh yeah crazy how do you know
that and i was like i learned it in
school
and he was like but like did someone in
school tell it to you and i was like oh
my teacher brought it up we read in the
book and he goes oh you read it in a
book
you believe that book and i was like
yeah i do he's like i read in the book
that jesus is the son of god and that he
came you know died for our sins and all
that stuff
is is my book wrong in your book right
and then i sort of laughed and i was
like i get your point
and his point was while there you i
think there's
legitimate and valid reasons to trust
science and why
i will look at a science book and talk
about you know elements and all that
stuff
people have people in their lives they
trust they've experiences they've seen
and things they trust and they believe
it
you haven't experienced what they
experience so you think something
different
how do you know they're wrong unless you
can prove a negative what you can't do
so it becomes very difficult
his ultimate point was like look man
there are a lot of people that read this
book and told them these things
and had people tell them that it was
true and they believe that
they believe it they've experienced that
the experts told them you think the
experts tell you but he's like when did
you pull an electron microscope and look
at that oxygen
that that molecule that atom and i was
like i never did and he's like well
shouldn't you
if you want to believe in it and you
want to claim you need to see the
evidence when was the last time
anybody who claims to believe in science
actually did the experiment to prove it
to themselves they didn't
so before you start talking about how
you think someone else is wrong because
of their religion
the first thing you can do is actually
do the experiments to track radio waves
and you can do it you absolutely can do
it
but people don't do it is the point so
this guy wasn't like
a really good zelda or anything he's
making a point about philosophy and how
you've got a lot of people who think
they're smarter than other people
and it could be a religious person who
thinks they're smarter than those who
deny the religion and say oh
you just don't know what you're talking
about and you've got these people who
say oh no you're crazy
you're talking about i'm smarter when in
reality it's just people who they trust
what they believe what they've
experienced
and sometimes you can't change that it's
crazy though and it really
you know helped shape my view of
everything like you know this guy was
pretty religious but he's making his
best
science is incomplete and i think that
that's where with all these views when
you read stories about aliens where
people come into this
is i feel like this the question of
aliens is actually more philosophy and
spiritual than it is a scientific
question
a lot of people talk about science like
it's a religion you know like do you
believe in
in this and they don't realize the
science is is so limited in the fact
that it's just testing
the physical world to you know through
hypotheses to create theories
and i think that people look at
scientists and bureaucrats today like
the bureaucrats are like
the priests or like the gods and the
scientists are somehow like the
theologians studying and predicting the
world
specifically right now with the left
saying the right doesn't believe in
science while they
literally ignore the lockdown science
and ignore the world health organization
they selectively choose what science
they support and what they oppose i'm
like i have a degree in science what do
you have and i ask people that i mean
it's not that extensive
but it's like to be honest it's like i
can tell you that it's genuinely a very
limited thing
but science today isn't even science
it's just predictive programming of like
whatever they want you to believe in
science today it's very political
yeah but i'm just saying for a long time
and that's and that's the left who have
been
so i just worked for environmental
nonprofits and the left was always
complaining about
researchers that were paid off by you
know major corporations
that's what they've all those those
scientists do that study well they were
paid off by big oil
and i'm like okay like well so that you
don't believe the science
is that report wrong for your political
reason that's why i've always been like
yo
these people just want power they'll
claim the sciences on their side if it
supports what they
want that's just about it we gotta go to
super chats
if we because we have not already so if
you haven't smash
the like button share subscribe all that
good stuff and uh we're gonna go in your
super chats so thanks for hanging out
everybody we do the show monday friday
live at 8 pm
let's see what people are saying we got
the first super chat of the day jonathan
galterini says i just want to say i love
you and be nice to your co-stars
i'll try luke yeah you son of a gun
son of a gun dj zeno says
the tree of liberty is thirsty tim yikes
no bipartisan banking schemes we choose
peace love and freedom
let's see flimsy fox the big old super
chat says hey tim
uh they say that they're a gay furry
leftist who supports trump
and actually support i'm not kidding
flimsy fox says they support donald
democrat policies but left the left as
soon as quote soyboys started playing
dirty and starting riots
i mean look welcome there are a lot of
people who left the left for these
reasons
there are a lot of people supporting
trump who are actually populists
but will choose to support trump over
the establishment because establishment
won't deliver
the furry furry gays so let's see uh
colin p says did you catch in the trump
phone call
that the georgia secretary of state said
their comparison between dominion voting
machines and their hand retalia were
virtually the same was that poor word
choice is there something here
well it's they're not the same you know
that's the issue loganor says for the
love of god tim i'm begging you to stop
pretending you know how the military
rank structure works
you're amazing at making non-ncos sound
like mindless npcs
why what did i what did i say that made
uh non-ncos
so just commissioned officers well it
says non ncos so non-non-commissioned
officers i think is when you're talking
about the national guard
and the coup so i actually lived on a
military base and uh
i lived outside of one and that's what
my experience is based on
so actually having a military family
living
on in base housing with my sister and
then living outside of
uh just just outside of fort eustis and
newport news
when my brother was in the army and i we
hung out i know these people all the
time
and that's what my opinion is based off
of so it's not like it's a it's an
opinion based on the entirety of the
military but it's at least based on my
experience with the people who are there
on those bases let's see
jake dog says elijah should have brought
his puppy and sydney
yeah you got a dog you bring your dog
and sydney's my neighbor
oh okay your neighbor bring your
neighbor
hey sure carl flynn says tim i ran out
of characters the other day
carl casarda made international
headlines back in 2018 after youtube's
gun content bans
he isn't really political beyond being
pro first and second amendment my uh
might be of interest to you is he the
dude who does the slingshot channel is
that him or that somebody else
i don't know that'd be cool to get this
i've never known of a slingshot channel
well so so he was doing i i i
disagreed with him he wanted to do a
youtube union and then i was like
i remember hearing about that terrible
idea i totally disagree with it and i
wouldn't want to be involved in anything
like that
and i'm really i really really don't
like the idea
of a system like that i'm not a fan of
unions
i'm a fan of collective bargaining i'm a
fan of getting everyone together and
then
making demands i'm not a fan of
organizing a legitimate union structure
for youtube
because then you get corruption politics
garbage and then you can't just work by
yourself and then what would happen is
because i've worked inside i've been in
several unions before
i see how the dirty politics plays and i
see other people get their benefits
and then i see how it hinders and hurts
the people who are at the bottom
struggling to
to stay afloat so i'm not a fan i don't
know why i
i don't think that's the same guy i'm
just bringing it up i'm not a fan of
that for whatever
my name is tim and i don't like unions
and i said that during during occupy
wall street
they had this panel at the um some
broadcasting center or whatever
and so they had a bunch of occupy people
and then some dude stands up and so it's
like
you guys all talk about this but none of
you will call it union corruption and i
was like i can't stand unions and then
everyone's like oh
like what but you're occupy wall street
and i was like no i love collective
bargaining
i love it when the workers rise up and
say you can't treat us this way and they
can they have their right to negotiate
but unions have become something totally
different and i've been
in them and my family my family members
have been in them and that's where my
experience come from
so i've seen too much corruption to
support that kind of stuff
let's see uh goat roofer says that was a
female proud boy supporter
who pulled the female antifaherton it
was a woman i thought it was a dude
well i must be wrong that's you know
genders exist
so a female proud boy female proud boy
supporter
why don't you ask them what they
identified by during that moment yeah i
think that's a good idea
all right let's see justin bookman says
the storied writers of this election are
copying a podcast called
terms i've been hearing some rumors of a
trucker protest against deliveries to dc
it's hard to get guys to go there now
high lids unlike some beanie weary
wearer i acknowledge you're here
when people watch your show and insult
you oh yeah of course so totally
well i actually seek out the
condescending and insulting ones as well
you know what's the worst thing someone
said about you on
a comment you accidentally read oh she's
accidentally ready or did you
hear this well i mean like did something
come out you're like oh shoot that was
like
totally violated the guidelines oh yeah
yeah yeah you ever see that when you
read it you go yeah i can't read that
out loud oh yeah i'll stop halfway
but like no no like when we have guests
like i'll see something it's like oh wow
that person is mean i'm going to read it
like what's the point creative writers i
might put them on blast no but like if
people are going to comment things
disparagingly
in like super chat do i just be like
well i refuse to think
say things that are mean to me no i'll
read it i'll i'll i'll read whatever if
i see the comment and then i'm looking
through it and i read it just don't
break the rules
carl flynn says fellas sean parnell just
pointed this out the other day
military service members swearing out to
the constitution not any individual
okay so will they defend the
constitution isn't that what we said
we still have a constitution i mean we
used to
can someone enlighten me what that is i
haven't heard of it recently
all right let's see matt ellie says make
good decisions in these trying times
move into the mountains buy a gun
tame a skinwalker what is it what is
that
skinwalkers from like our first episode
oh yeah the navajo skinwalkers that's
right i thought that was like a wife or
something
oh here we go you guys ready z-dub says
similarities between the rise of julius
caesar and trump
julius was called to answer for crimes
for the invasion of
german lands it was either jail or death
or fight
i would argue trump has more support
than julius that's what i've been saying
man
you've got this they've ramped up the
criminal probe into trump in new york
using bringing in financial forensic
analysts they're gonna i don't think
biden of the federal government go after
trump because they got that like oh we
want to arrest you you don't arrest us
but there's a bunch of state level
zealots who are like we're going to
arrest trump and lock them up and trump
knows it
they're not just going after him it's a
trump organization they're going to go
after his business his legacy and his
family
does trump just say well it was a good
run
and i'm gonna go to prison now and just
leave the white house or does he go
no no i'm not leaving you are not
locking anybody up we won
and stay oh trump gets trump gets
arrested for something that's that's not
even provable
that's a war honestly it's an act of war
everybody leaves office
i think if they arrest them for
something that they can't prove is
worthy of it like they find it
come on mitch i think some people would
would react the media has put out years
of garbage about russia they'll just say
it's true
drug lords can get broken out of jail by
their cartels i mean this loyalty is
something you should do from your guys's
experience covering uh recent protests
what do you think is going to happen in
dc
on the sixth oh
uh well it depends how many trump
supporters show up i mean honestly
speaking if if it's like above 100 000
or 200 000 which i'm assuming it'll
probably be
um it's going to be way more than that
well that's what i'm just saying like
just putting
the estimates from the last one that
they said oh there was a couple hundred
thousand or so
uh i mean realistically speaking it
depends on to what extent what groups
and instigators i'm more worried about
false flags i think that there could be
people that could be sent in
to cause mayhem i mean the fact that
people keep saying and prepping there's
gonna be violence
hold on if someone tried false flagging
a trump supporter
i don't think it would have the reaction
you'd think it would
so typically we think of false flags
like you fly the flag of your enemy to
make them look bad to make them seem
like the bad guys or whatever
but i think if someone tried doing it
the trump supporters it'd probably
not have the intended consequences like
it would not make trump supporters go oh
no trump is bad uh what have they done
we can't support this it's gonna make
people be
like well people have finally snapped
like i don't i don't think it's gonna
i don't think you'll get the reaction
people would expect can it make history
change just like wikipedia
you know comes in and calls everybody
some alt-right person even if there's
not the evidence based off of somebody
else's misgiving
characterization is it to rewrite and
aggregate or not but i'm saying isn't
this is this their whole point to
rewrite histories at the very end
they can rewrite what the last gathering
of trump supporters to teach future
generations that these were bad people
maybe but so uh look i don't know what's
going to happen but
has trump ever called for people to show
up to one of his protests before
i have not seen that in the years
working what about what about the mother
of all rallies trump didn't endorse that
or anything did he
not the last couple of them no did he
ever when was the last time a president
called for a protest
on the vote count day he didn't call for
a protest technically right he called
for us to meet
at a certain point so like that's a very
well he said there's gonna be a protest
to be there it'll be
wild yeah you didn't call for the
protest to meet somewhere where there is
something and he's
already going to be approached correct
so like but the point is yeah with
last month when there are estimates of
100 to 200k
throughout dc uh trump didn't say
be here in dc he didn't call for his
supporters to arrive
when it came to trump's inauguration and
not that many people showed up relative
to say obama
it's because they didn't need to he won
they're watching online at home
trump has now said several times be
there trump supporters are gonna show up
have you heard of the next news network
yeah of course okay that's what i
just want to bring up a point here is
like the next news network
is a a youtube show no people haven't
heard of gary franchot
i've known him yeah good good guys but
like that has like two million
subscribers and it's been going up and
then like blaze we've always been from
blaze tv we've always been like a
paywall content site we just started
working on our youtube
it got like well over like 1.3 million
in one year
the point being is like these trump
people that are following the populist
movement and what's going on
like i mean look at your channels how
much they've blown up my point being is
protests aside so only so many people
can physically travel if you look at the
rise of like free thinking and
independent channels that look out for
the populace whether it's left
libertarian
or gary francie or blaze tv more like
center right people who love america
these channels are exploding in growth
which shows that not only are we gaining
power and access to information
but i think that this is just like the
beginning of a new movement
like we saw it growing and i think now
that we have like how can we get so many
people there
it's because the influence of so many
free thinking people has gotten to the
point where the information disseminates
outside of the normal barriers of of big
tech and the establishment media i mean
i'm
really excited for what this begins
right this is a good start to 2021 if
you're a populist person
right on paul luckett says the thing
about soldiers just taking orders and
never asking questions is total bs
people like jocko willink a former navy
seal seal
task unit commander talk about that a
lot go listen to his stuff
the issue is i think people have a
movie-esque view
of what this means like i said what
happens if some guy says
hey guys we're going to need you to go
and lock down this bridge there's a
threat we got a bunch of people coming
in so nobody should be going across
you know this one's going to be shut
down all right sounds good no one's
going to defy that order they're going
to be like sounds good
we're going to go stand guard and
protect a bridge that's not obscene it's
not absurd
but what if that is a you know key
junction point for some kind of
political you know
politician or whatever and you're the
point is
in turkey there was a coup attempt i'm
doing air quotes
where a bunch of soldiers showed up to
the bridge standing around and then a
helicopter started firing at him it was
a crazy moment
and then erdogan of turkey said oh it's
a coup attempt they're trying to
you know to shut down the government
steal power from the people and then the
regular people ran up and started
beating the crap out of the soldiers who
were there
and what i was what i was told at the
time and there's probably been further
reporting on it is
the soldiers were just low-ranking dudes
who were told hey go guard the bridge
and they said you got it
they said there might be a terror attack
you got it and they showed up and then
on the media they said it's a coup
attempt and so the regular people went
and just started dragging the soldiers
to the street being beaten yeah for that
person i have a two-word
response pat tillman
what happened what was i i know this was
a friendly fire incident of
afghanistan uh nfl professional player
that literally
went and joined to fight the war on
terror and the government covered up and
lied what actually happened to him
there's a lot of his family members that
are calling out at the foul
practices that led up to his unfortunate
death
that happened because of friendly fire
and not because of what
the government's official story was this
is interesting
josh bushnell says how far apart are we
to be to buy or sell
six feet apart like this 6-6-6
revelation 13 18 this calls for wisdom
let the one who has understanding
calculate the number of the beast
for it is the number of a man and his
number is 666.
interesting we'll see let's see
johan oldman says money in your bank
account is just the sum total of all the
transactions that have happened on your
account
the bank that was closed was probably
found out for invalid accounting
perhaps i think the guy was losing his
job and he's like i don't care whatever
all right let's see what do we got here
some more super chats
joe mk2 says communism originated from
the occult
china unscripted did a great episode
last week on it the devil is in the
details
interesting really you didn't know that
i gotta watch that video
okay here we go ray hummer says wet
wipes are actually very bad for any
septic system
whether it be in city or rural i think
it says rules as rule
even if they are biodegradable do not
flush them personally cost me 600
in my septic system yes you people don't
you city folk don't get it you know you
got a plumbing system
you live out in the country you got a
septic system oh you better stop people
from flushing
you know dirty garbage you got an rv you
got even more problems
oh yeah because you're carrying it
around that's the funny thing about
getting an rv it's like all of that poop
just sits right there
in your possession until you you know
find a way to get rid of it
bakes in your possession thank you all
right let's see we got
ben schwen says pm me if you want to if
you want to talk to someone
that knows exactly how the online
financial system works i'm a dev that
spent four years building software for
the biggest processor in the us
it's way more complex than you think the
fed sees every exchange
interesting grim pickens says speaking
of movie propaganda
ever noticed that the de septicons aka
the bad guys were all military vehicles
and a cop car
wayne omen says marvel civil war if you
were pro captain america you believe in
freedom
if you were team iron man you are pro
lockdown you liked you liked iron man i
liked captain america
i remember that distinctly no we're
morals you're like i'm a captain
i've never said that well
it was like a couple years ago you're
are you sure yeah you're iron man's the
best and i was like nope captain america
is because he believes
there's no way the milk we had a whole
argument
joined the team of iron man you liked
iron man i remember distinctively you
being on team iron you're wrong
it's just ridiculous i could be i don't
know i was i wasn't i was i was sitting
there probably
you know bloviating or philosophizing on
like
the merits of either argument probably i
didn't support when those movies
i wasn't like yeah go iron man
corporatist industrialist telling
everyone to bow to the government woohoo
yeah that's exactly what i'm all about i
just remember distinctively being like
okay i'm captain america you're iron man
no but we had a conversation about this
too and i remember you making some
arguments and points
specifically arguing for iron man
right yeah but i didn't i was saying
there are pros and cons to
there's pros and cons to
authoritarianism i was like nah man
captain america is way better and he's
cooler and he's fighting for america
even though the actors
going out and saying a lot of crazy
stuff that's what it's really about i
was like actually robert downey jr is
pretty cool but chris evans kind of lost
the plot
yeah and you were like no way man no i
don't know and i was like
what happened what happened to you man
all right joe harris says
you brought up music and the message in
the song have you listened to tom
mcdonald
he's an independent artist raps about
really controversial topics highly
suggest
people so stupid and no lives matter and
white boy yes
tom mcdonald's amazing i listen to a ton
of his stuff he's got great videos too
really really really awesome stuff yeah
for sure
brewmaster monk says i'm almost too
stoned for this conversation
well apparently not not too stoned not
stoned
here we go celtic reese says revelation
12 verse 1 and 2 occurred september 23rd
24th 2017. please look into this
you want to look that up luke revelation
12
verse one and two and then he says it
happened in september of 2017. let's see
what they say
all right let's see we've got a big
youtube jump of super chats
johnny buns says tim i'm looking at the
us government
throw the dollar down the drain so i
took my nest egg invested in it
by 2028 i'm going to make a great return
on my rosetta stone stock
that's right mandarin or you can i don't
know the legality is for
foreign exchange uh but uh you can buy
chinese one i guess
although i wouldn't really actually
recommend any of that
red red on says i'm a gorilla love
yourself
the the the slogan is uh about the woman
of the apocalypse
i don't know if you want me to read it
but just a bit the text describes a
woman clothed with
the sun and the moon under her feet and
upon her head a crown of 12 stars
that's that when did that happen who was
that
it says the woman is pregnant and about
to give birth traveling and birth
and pain to be delivered that's what
came up someone said
tim assange posted bail exclamation
point is that true
is he out is he free well i know the
united states government is challenging
the decision this morning what if they
don't know if
they could still grant him bail and he
can for the first time in his life walk
around outside i guess
and then for the first time in the past
decades i mean mexico is considered
considering giving him asylum yeah
yeah eric douglas has great trump
impression tim i wasn't even trying to
really do a trump impression i was just
giving you a light one
uh publia says do you think trump would
invite a bunch of people to dc to watch
him lose
also elijah is sydney looking for
citizenship
sydney's a dual citizen she's a she
already sorry but she is single
oh oh a youtuber sydney watson yeah you
should have her on
uh she's american i think i invited her
on
wow she's just really i ever on my show
all the time and she's people always go
i don't even watch him she's better
which is true but there you go
wait a second elijah zepeda says can you
talk more about demonology and how do
you think it relates to psychedelics
oh i could do that yeah give it give us
give us a minute or two give us a riff
all right well demonology is saying
that's not really talked about a lot in
the bible there's not a lot
you know specifically you know played on
it but there is something interesting is
that
you know there's a word used that for
witchcraft that's called like pharmakia
or pharmacology
and it's not talking about you know for
instance there's a point in the new
testament where they talk about using
alcohol or different things
for sickness this is and it's being okay
for believers it's not talking about
you know people taking advil or like
just normal pharmacy it means there was
a there was a combination between a lot
of like witch doctors and witchcraft and
actually psychedelics
um and connected to people who were like
following the devil and darkness
uh in the bible and so it's kind of
interesting that one of the one of the
forbidden
realms for christians was like to not
engage in this pharmacology of this
abuse of substances
that translucent your mind because it
actually can put you under the influence
of the enemy and i think the question i
would ask myself that not just with
demonology but
to argue the point of people who are
pro-psychedelic something does switch in
your brain
and that's why even when we talk about
the story of adam and eve and awakening
to a new reality
people always talk about there being an
apple even though the bible never talks
about that
and even if you don't believe in the
bible you think it's an allegory like
there is something in our brains that
can wake up and there's
there are substances that can change our
brain to think differently and i do
think that it's interesting that a lot
of people
who do these substances either see
beings of light or beings of darkness
and a lot of times people who describe
demons who don't use psychedelics
describe the demons
or the angels the same way that people
on psychedelics describe their
interactions so there's that that common
sense and there's my two-minute spew
right on silently in atlanta says big
difference between science versus truth
what if people couldn't bluntly share
prophecy they'd use poetic language to
warn you
because what if someone powerful is
listening here's homework watch the star
twilight zone science meets religion i
will put it on literally once we finish
this show
i love the twilight zone that sounds
like a lot of fun
l-l-k-a warrudo says
god is the ultimate scientist changed my
mind i think the angels and demons are
in another dimension
but here among us on the other side of
the veil but i also believe demons only
have power
if we give it interesting
i think someone thought we're talking
about sydney powell sydney i saw powell
i'm not i don't think anyone's trying to
date sydney powell we need to just
lynn wood up in here talk about
demonology too convincing reality says
the clear reason drugs would cause
similar hallucinations in people is
because we all share the same human
brains
instinct instinct and basic cultural
norms seeing any perceived unknown as
good or bad as necessary
as we are wired to react in terms of
survival the other important thing to
realize is that
if a culture or a you know a culture
doesn't have a concept for a word
you literally can't translate or
describe it to someone like there there
are uh
instances i'm sure if any of you have
ever worked with someone who's bilingual
where they'll be talking about something
and they'll say there's a word and
they'll say it
like i don't really know how to how to
describe it in english but it's my try
yeah but it's like yes but it's not the
same necessarily
like there they have you know the call
of the void i think it is
yes in french the feeling you get when
you're standing atop a high location you
have the urge to jump down lots of words
like that
there's words for like specific feelings
there's one word in like an african
culture
that describes the feeling you have when
you're in love with
uh when when a man loves a woman but she
loves a different man instead and so
he's both jealous angry
and you know depressed at the same time
and that's like one small word to
explain that whole phenomenon
like like kurva which is a word that you
can't say that yes i can
this is youtube it's english english
youtube so it's technically you know
yeah it's fine right it's family
friendly or cool
that's another one of them and again
this is why i have a lot of brain farts
because i originally was speaking
polish and uh it's it flips sometimes is
there is there is there a non-offensive
word in polish that doesn't translate to
english very well
um i got to think of one you have a
polish name yeah
what is it it's a secret it's a secret i
can't tell you
if you indoctrinate you if people found
out luke's real name you don't you shush
[Laughter]
no you can look up luke caskey you'll
find you'll find nothing
that's true you'll find you'll you'll
find all of that i've been depressed
isn't that cool you can change your name
and then just change your identity
and it's actually true you really can no
luke's real name people would be like no
way can we change the topic yeah
it's gonna trend now yep people are
gonna try and figure it out
they'll never find it no they never will
they won't
dk says consider taking some
psychedelics tim it really open up your
mind and expand your perspective on
everything
you do mental gymnastics to explain the
unexplainable there's more to life than
what we see
perhaps or maybe luke can talk about
that and i can
have there's gonna be so many
conspiracies about me now just because
of what you said before there's already
a bunch of crazy ones luke changed his
name and he has some special knowledge
about psychedelics unlocking something
he may even have some in his pocket
right
well when it comes to psychedelics i
urge people to please do your own
research
it's not for everyone it really has to
be something that you truly feel very
strongly about
and it's a personal decision that you
should make for yourself and not be
influenced by anyone else
clearly we're talking about only in the
states that have decriminalized of
course
because i think colorado did recently
right right i think it's society's
decriminalizing california
well i'm pretty sure foreign and i think
there's even been some development in
mexico
you are following all applicable laws
yeah just check out the scientific
studies especially when it comes to
these
uh instances the grand story says the
revelations thing is related to a star
sign it matched an exact uh it matched
an exact and one-time cosmic event
involving stars planets and moon in
2017.
that's what that person was talking
about interesting i found it abel garcia
says tim i have a question for elijah
elijah i know you're probably busy at
the moment especially with the sixth
coming up
but when could we have a second
interview this is abel garcia from
episode 38. do you know abel garcia is
somebody who went through full
transition in surgery and then decided
that
they felt like they were brainwashed and
pressed into getting the full surgery
and like
made to accept their gender difference
and they wanted to
uh reverse it all and then end up
getting rejected by the trans
community in the gay community in
california and it's like
such a it was such a it's like sorry
that's a whole other conversation but
that's like absolutely mind-boggling
i think that abel has my phone number
you can text me so cal exile says on the
demon stuff check out a book called
spirit of the rain forest about an
indian tribe in the amazon
interesting let's see uh jay mill says
future guests david barton
amazing historian viva frey and robert
barnes incredible legal discussions
the problem with uh viva frey and barnes
is that uh frey is in canada i believe
yes what is that stinkbug
it's the devil he's attacking us that
thing is over here it's the antichrist
he landed on me little just distinct i
like snake bugs though they're really
clumsy and
this is what cia wants you to think
little cameras flying around
they use dolphins to minimize chinese
they're the bourgeoisie
all right let's see john 117 says if you
want something epic to look forward to
at the end of time satan will assume the
form of a seven-headed red dragon and be
slain by jesus
is that true lots of symbology there is
that is that is that true it's symbolic
in revelation yeah
is it but what if it's literal like what
if literally you know
i'm not gonna name anybody but some like
elite you know wealthy industrialist
just goes like raw and his head splits
into seven
and then like literally a dude
stereotypically looking like jesus
pulls out a sword and i'd be more likely
to believe that's happening than
the lockdowns are working you know it's
a little more believable
i mean well you get a top world world
health organization scientists saying we
should avoid this
we can avoid this you have to wonder why
they're still doing it against the
science
like the it doesn't make sense to build
us back better tim you know that
yup just like they're doing in europe
tom up
gucci slipper says elijah
pharmakia can also be applied to
vaccines the original
and still used vaccine formula was from
a fetus blood magic is strictly
prohibited
wow creepy brewmaster monk says luke is
a roth child
you could say anything about my hairline
my nose my physical looks but that that
hurt me
i'm offended and uh triggered
very much that's true that's such an
interesting like modern
insults like yes that's a hard world
that's a bad one here this is
interesting this is interesting chris
says
the staff and serpent first aid is the
staff of
aslepius his father was apollo and his
mother was coronas the story was written
by ovid
interesting corona i watched some really
trippy like youtube video
years ago about like the snakes
spiraling and they were like doesn't it
look like dna like a double helix
how did they know speaking of mythology
did you guys see wonder woman in 1984
yes yes absolutely terrible
unfortunately
you know what i say no well look it was
a movie like
if you sit down and the movie's playing
and you're just like kind of not really
paying attention it's just happening
beautiful main character
yeah i mean gal gano's great uh wishing
rock it's commanding
no but the human wishing rock is the
main plot he was a good actor he was the
only good actor no i love pedro pastor
yeah he's great
but this was clearly uh it was they
wanted to make trump the villain
and they needed to figure out how to do
it and he has that famous line in the
movie
well i say famous but like he goes i am
a tv personality
and respected businessman and and then
the guy goes you're a fraud and a con
man i am not i am not a con man
it was like that's pretty good i get it
you should have been an actor
i was like i get it you guys they said
they wanted the villain to be donald
trump
okay we get it we get it he was on the
tv life is good
but it can be better kate mckinnon also
poor casting like she's really
no you that was christian christian wig
sorry they all they're the same to me
but
kristen wiig the that girl she's like
goofy and she her whole first
part made sense i was like oh she's that
goofy girl and then all of a sudden
we're supposed to take her as like
something like
serious like i'm not gonna ruin it for
anyone but some like serious character i
don't know typecasting didn't work
you know no i'll tell you what happened
you know what happened with that movie
they were like we have
you know 20 different story points how
do we connect them and i don't know
and so like we'll just we'll just film
it and then we'll just make something up
was it justice league
or batman vs superman where wonder woman
literally tells bruce wayne like
oh i went into hiding for like 100 years
after the events of
the first wonder woman movie and then
all of a sudden she's back in 1984.
oh and she's running around in her she's
lying in her costume like no no no
no like i'm a spoiler alert for those
who haven't seen it i don't know if you
care don't bother
there's yeah there's a scene in the
trailer there's a scene in the trailer
where she lassos lightning and
swings from lightning right yes hold on
but she can also fly so it's like why
did that happen
literally for no reason just randomly
for no reason at all there's a scene
where she's in the air and then she
whips lightning and you're like okay
was i confused but where did that gold
costume come from i don't know it just
magically appears
or just got gold and you're like from
the sky i got it stored away in her
apartment well this is a little this is
little known fact about wonder woman
she has the ability to uh have gold
spikes emerging where bones and ripped
through her flesh kind of like wolverine
but all over her body and it's
there was there was a deleted scene
where a very grotesque gold is bursting
from her face
it's like it's like cronenberg have you
ever seen like the fly or those old
movies from the 80s
i'm kidding it's like in the movie she's
just like
floating through the air and then also
in the next scene and she's wearing
armor it's like okay
like i have no idea i think i bet you
there's a plot issue and there was one
of those movies it was such a train
wreck
they just started like cutting pieces of
the film together and we're like all
right
you get this it's like pandemic and they
couldn't explain why cheetah was a
cheetah
it's just like all of a sudden she's an
animal on the graphics they lost the
budget like three-fourths through the
movie and they were like all right
we got to use the budget the budget uh
production house for this one and it was
like not even believable
i know it was like a cheat it shouldn't
be believable but it was really bad it's
too bad too because i think
it's like really easy to have fixed what
was wrong with that movie
if you just like adjust certain things
in certain places but this is true
it's true for so many movies that come
out you know i think they got ruined i
think kovid destroyed the movie
like they earlier the year it was come
out in june or whatever
and i think they probably were
restricted on doing a bunch of things
they had to do a bunch of reshoots in
2019 they did
in 2019 whenever you see a movie you
have to do reshoots you know there's a
problem from the very beginning
yeah they watched it and they were like
wait how did that happen i don't know
it's like we just filmed it okay did who
wrote the script the sound was perfect
and the color correction was on point
and you're like well there's no story
it's just like her movements like
throughout the year she's very like
robotic and it's just like am i watching
like wonder woman that was made
like actually 30 years ago it really was
going on there
well i'll tell you wonder woman 1984 has
nothing to do with anything dc
and it's and people were saying they've
stopped doing the whole universe thing
because if you watch wonder 1984 you're
like justice league makes no sense
at all it's just literally no sense it's
sad too i was so excited for that movie
the trailer was awesome
and then the movie was just not i was
happy that chris pine
was coming back and his character just
literally meant nothing the problem with
this movie
so spoiler alerts again okay now that
i've warned you about the spoilers
you've got this wishing stone and when
you wish for something
you get what you wish for but it takes
your most prized possession
and so that's just like the stupidest
thing ever because if you could wish
whatever you wanted you'd value it more
than your most prized possession
like the plot was just dumb i know how
about this talk about like this forced
diversity issue
why did the guy had anyone explain how
he just had like a total like full-on
chinese kid or asian kid
and that was not a mixed-race kid it was
like full-on like some other ethnicity
i'm not sure
i might sound racist saying it was it
chinese but i was like he's like a white
guy blonde hair was like
hey son and it was like some kid from
like what's that horror movie with a
little
asian kid and it was like he was just
like standing there and it wasn't it
wasn't chinese
i would i would say maybe there was no
resemblance maybe vietnamese or filipino
one of the others yeah maybe like
filipino but even then i was going i
don't think filipinos they're just like
we need an asian in the movie no no
no no no no no no no we're in an asian
in the movie we'll get make this crying
kid no but like
uh it's it's a weird thing actually
cause like
i i i you you notice it right like pedro
pascal
is he's he's what he's
hispanic or he's yeah i don't know where
he's he's like white hispanic probably
and so he's got a kid who's and i'm like
i guess my immediate assumption was like
he adapted a kid
you know i would i was thinking that
like he found the kid like i wasn't
confused i thought it was gonna make
those comedies it's like wait a second
you're not my son
what are you doing in here but the kid
had nothing to do with anything it made
no sense there's no point that's what
i'm saying they were like oh we gotta
get an asian and they just like put him
in the film so like there was diversity
and it didn't make me and it was weird
how like it would randomly show the kid
just his face crying and i'm like what
does it have to do with anything he's
just like joining the kid again and he's
crying again like what is this yeah so
much lazy subliminal propaganda in there
i was like
this is just it's just donald trump is
the villain though yeah
he's got like wavy blonde hair i am a
television personality
and a respected businessman you're a
fraud in the continent i am not a gunman
i don't know but the part i just just
the end where like
he's you pedro pascal is like using like
invisible
wind to like keep wonder woman away like
this is the same person that could like
take a headbutt from freaking superman
made
no sense and like wind bro yeah no but i
love how it's like
the premise is that he has to if people
are touching him and make a wish
then he can grant the wish but take
something from them and so he's like
the radio waves are touching people
they're like yes the radios are touching
people
that means i can use what yeah that
makes no sense
and the best part and then she was like
i am not talking to myself
i'm talking and then he's like there's
like something like lasso touching some
guy's leg and he's in some super saiyan
mode
and then here's the best part like what
was this about how like
everyone just saw some person say
something on tv they're like oh my gosh
there's an above average woman telling
me to do something hey
make sense by mass compliance i'm gonna
do it right now and like everybody did
and the best part about this is
spoiler is like did you notice when like
things were reversing in the world and
things were happening
that like people's houses that got
destroyed didn't like get fixed like
like when the wall went back down
everyone's houses was still in rubble so
they're like oh
cool and everyone just forgets the whole
world was about to blow up and then like
everyone then it's snowing and then like
people are happy again you're going oh
this is definitely shot before covet
that's all i was thinking i was like
it's this you know i'm sorry man but if
the plot of a movie is there's a rock
that can grant literally any wish you
want
that and in exchange for your most
prized possession why would the dude
wish to be the rock
that's that's the spoiler alert he goes
i wish i was you and then and then this
it collapses and then he gains the
powers to grant wishes that's like why
why wouldn't you just wish to like you
know like have
magic powers i guess i don't know like
you could literally turn into a giant
cheetah monster
or cause the whole plan to explode you
and you couldn't wish for literally
anything you'd be like i wish i had
all the powers of the dreamstone but for
myself yeah he's just like no i want to
grant wishes for other people it's like
that's why and they never really
explained anything like where this came
from now
by the way this is a confession i don't
watch i don't watch any
marvel movies this is the first marvel
movies
okay there you go people are going to
hate me i don't watch superhero movies
in general
after the pandemic i've watched even
less movies so this is my first
reintroduction back into the superhero
movies everyone keeps telling me they're
so good
you've got to watch them they're amazing
i was like all right fine fine i'll go
see 1984.
maybe i have i been making the right
decision or am i just getting tricked
here wonder woman the first one was good
it was really good yeah should i go
watch the first one
yeah it's great it's a world war one
movie and it's it's pretty cool
like the scene where they're firing the
rifles at her and she's got her shield
and it's like she's getting hit
like that's cool but this one was just
like
what that's what you say like every so
often you're like a scene changes and
then the story is just different you're
like huh
they're like release this movie now
they're waiting till like the world was
falling apart they're like people will
just watch this because it's something
like that
i think i think there were problems with
it they couldn't fix because of covet
i think that was that was i have to
reshoot some serious scenes for that
movie well they needed to connect things
they needed simple explanations to
connect things like wonder woman just
magically having armor
like it's like she's she's like standing
there and she's like whips lightning and
then the next scene is she's flying with
golden wings and you're like
what like what's going on and then like
and then kristen wiig turns into a
cheetah and you're like but why
why is she an animal now like it made no
sense
it like the movie defy those plot holes
man yeah i'm a
like a feline or you become what you
hate the most like she hated no she's
she wished to be like no she wished to
be
like uh uh diana and so then she
basically gains god powers but she had a
cat i was figuring because she doesn't
like cats no no she says i wish i was
like diana so then she
gains wonder woman's powers but then
later on he asks her again and she goes
i want to be a predator so you know you
don't get two wishes yeah
they they made that clear in the movie
you don't get two wishes and then she
turns into an animal
like did she end up dying or not i
couldn't figure that out
no she renounced her wish and turned so
she just got like massively electrocuted
she's like that
by the way i don't encourage you to
throw your cat into an electrocution you
know chamber of water oh
oops that's what happens but like yeah
it's just i'm sorry man if the premise
of the movie is you can
you can wish for literally anything you
want and they're like i wish i was
powerful but not quite powerful enough
to be defeat wonder woman
that why would you make that wish why
wouldn't you be like i wish i was
completely
undefeatable and ultimately you know had
ultimate strength and power i wish i was
bad cgi
wish granted yeah speaking of hollywood
have you heard about the civil war and
lucasfilms
no no really so lucas films i'm not
going to give a spoiler here but
oh i talk about the mandalorian they
brought back a particular
white superhero and all the sjws and
lucasfilms are absolutely
pissed well just like if you haven't if
you haven't been following the
mandalorian
i mean this was like two episodes ago or
i mean the episodes are out so they
should have seen it by now so they
brought luke skywalker back
yep that's the finale right and there
was just an outrage and the sjws and
lucasfilms are just not
i mean that guy's star wars theory on
youtube one of the lucas films
uh not an executive but i think one of
the like one of the creators that was
involved with the last jedi
because uh star wars theory for those
that know his channel he's he's huge
right
uh he gave his reaction on the episode
and he was crying because a lot of
people were like
this is this is a big moment for star
wars fans especially after the last jedi
and one of the lucasfilms creators
criticized him on twitter
saying oh you're not supposed to show
your emotions or emotions are not to be
shown
and then he completely like backtracked
and lucasfilms even issued an apology
and the guy
gave like this freaking not even a full
apology it's like this whole drama so
ridiculous what i saw was that uh for
those that aren't familiar spoiler alert
oh well we already told you
luke skywalker is in the mandalorian and
apparently they're mad that he's a white
male hero who returned and they don't
like that
but isn't the mandalorian uh you know
white male
pedro pascal yeah i guess the same guy
yeah pedro pascal i got bored from the
mandalorian like after four episodes it
was the same plot every
episode and it gave me some reminiscence
and i'm finally coming to the conclusion
just like my conclusion about
how you know the police aren't always
good like star wars is definitely a
super cool series when you get into it
as a kid
and you don't understand and you don't
understand plot but as you get older you
realize that
it's exact example of hollywood taking
something that could be perfect
and just causing more problems than is
needed like the plot holes the storyline
sometimes the cheap cgi it's like you
almost feel like this movie could have
been the best series in the history of
the world and it's always cool to watch
but it's like what if the people who
made lord of the rings like peter
jackson made
star wars like as a producer with lucas
or something then maybe we could have
gotten something with
a lot more depth of character like
movies that made sense
star wars was revolutionary the first
movie because this was the 70s and
people hadn't seen
space battles before and it was like it
was like
rebel revolutions in cgi like a
lightsaber how they were doing this
stuff had never been done
so you're you're young or you know and
you go to the movies and you're
literally watching spaceships and you're
like
wow man so it's people don't realize i
think the movies were like years apart
like three years
like from star wars to empire strikes
back and then to like
return to the jedi these were huge
movies for the time that were
revolutions in in movie technology
and that was it and then that spawned
merchandise which made a ton of money
and it made a bunch of
the extended universe books and stuff
that explored the universe of star wars
which fans
loved and i don't know a whole lot about
but i did play knights of the old
republic which was a lot of fun i loved
that game those years ago when i played
that
awesome game by the way so then it's
just
how do we make more money prequels the
prequels were
okay i like them they're super corny
episode three was pretty cool i thought
but
i just rewatched it and i was like wow
this is the worst directing i have ever
seen
like it was just like bad soap soap
opera drama
just like annie yeah just like
everything's overly dramatic and absurd
and i was like
you know what i don't when i never
really liked about revenge of the sith
is how like
anakin skywalker just they make him
just break randomly there's no
progression in his character to him
becoming evil
like there's a little bit stuff like in
the previous movie he kills the women
and the children or whatever
and then you have in return of the sith
i just watched it again
because that line about when when
obi-wan says my allegiance is to
to the republic to democracy i was
actually planning on you know
doing that as a bit in one of my
segments where i was talking about
police i was going to be like
you have these these cops who believe
they're bringing you know peace justice
and security to their new empire
but their allegiance is supposed to be
to the republic to democracy and so i'm
going to watch this movie again and
boy is it just not it's like the
dialogue has been i like it
it's fun it's fun watching obi-wan fight
you know anakin and all stuff and
you know whatever but i think even with
the mandalorian right now
star wars was like hey we found
something popular can we turn it into
something more than that
and they're milking it for as much as
they can the the sequel movies were just
the worst garbage ever
you know uh um the force awakens was
okay but it was basically a
shot-for-shot remake of a new hope
and then the last jedi was one of the
worst movies i've ever seen in my life
i wanted to leave the theater but i was
like i can't it's star wars you know i
need to
like i need to watch it but man was that
bad i fell asleep in episode eight and
stopped star wars there
dude the what's the what's what's the la
what's the the the last no no what's the
sky right that was just so awful yeah
they're like
the the emperor has returned he's like
jump cuts
yeah right and i loved how they had to
bring carrie fisher back
and so she gives these one-word
non-answers
because they can't because she died you
know you know with respect rest in peace
but like they tried keeping her in the
movie and it was clear they had some old
footage from the previous movie they
were trying to somehow turn into
her giving statements but then she just
doesn't say anything and
you know froze her brow and then walks
away dude
if the creators of star wars were forced
to create a porno they would make it
star jaw by the hutt like that's how bad
that's how bad they are in my opinion
it's like really like that's
like every time i watch those movies
it's like about to like get into it i'm
like that's
really what you've done here like i mean
remember when like mace windu gets just
like randomly thrown out of the window
in episode three i'm going
really like this is okay
it's really what you know what really
annoys me is we just watched that movie
green land you have you guys heard of
that one with uh gerard butler
no i watched that that was one of the
worst yeah right i've seen recently it's
idiot plot
like a movie that's a movie's plot
driven by the fact that the main
characters are really dumb
i'm like why would i watch that i want
to watch a movie that's driven by
someone who's overcoming adversity
or who's facing a challenge outside of
their control and they're trying to
overcome it that's just me this is me
maybe maybe people like watching dumb
people fumble around and fall on their
face
dude insulin tim that was like the plot
of the story was like a kid needs
insulin when the world's ending and
you're going right
uh what okay but then like
they just show up and then they're let
in like come on in
you didn't need to do anything anyway it
just makes no sense the creators of
wonder woman 1984 would be like
i have an idea for a new movie starting
gerard butler we have half the time and
half the budget to produce it let's say
green light it
you know what we need you know what we
need we need a wishing rock yeah
we should make it bigger so it's a
meteor and it comes down to earth
yeah man it's it's you know so with
with that movie particularly the you
have all these movies that are
predicated upon
someone being dumb and then you're just
watching someone be dumb and then deal
with the mistakes of being dumb like why
would i want to watch that as a form of
entertainment
like why couldn't they have made that
movie you know so the whole plot
well i don't want to spoil that that
movie just came out didn't it greenland
yeah i just watched it i'm not going to
spoil it either it just came out yeah
come on it's like
okay give someone a motivation that's
outside of their control they have to
overcome
instead you get these movies like the
latest star wars just
it's just meaningless makes no sense and
what all they're really doing
and they do the same was true for
pirates of the caribbean they're like
look everybody it's that character you
like here they are dancing in front of
the camera and i'm like okay
just to sell that merch with the last
jedi i really felt like
like it made it it made sense because
like
luke is like in a slump and he has to
kind of find his way back
and i get it because luke was like that
from the very beginning in a new hope
he was this bratty teenage kid that
didn't believe in anything of the force
and then yoda tries to
train him and he's like still this
bratty kid that can't get anything done
he does he just doesn't believe so it
kind of made sense that luke
was kind of in that slump again in the
last jedi but it shouldn't have been the
whole movie
what i what i really liked about the
original star wars is that it's
basically about
uh this kid who lives in a desert planet
who gets radicalized by religious
zealots
to take a cargo ship and go blow up a
military base that's star wars
boom it is yeah anyway we
we've gone over quite a bit so how about
uh you smash that like button
thanks for hanging out tomorrow is the
start of the protests the six is the big
day
so far we're planning on being there but
we're going to have some some crew go
down and test everything so we can get
set up and then do the show there it'll
be a lot of fun
but uh guys thanks for for hanging out
you want to mention your youtube
channels or anything
yeah all right so you can check out my
podcast called slightly offensive
you can find it on apple podcast google
play youtube for free
it's really awesome comes out every
monday wednesday friday at 2 p.m central
and clips the following day
you guys can follow me on twitter drew h
live and my podcast is at the tatum
report
youtube channel uh drew h live and you
guys can find it there make sure to
subscribe
right on luke i hear that you have a
channel yes and i have a store company
that supports my voluntary efforts here
the sh
and the shirt that i'm wearing today
says fyi
the government is way deadlier than any
virus just my opinion if you like it you
can get it on teesprings.com forward
slash stores
forward slash we are change and you can
find me on
twitter and instagram under the handle
luke we are change
luke we are change thanks and of course
you can follow me on twitter instagram
parlor at tim cast you can check out my
other channels youtube.comcast and
youtube.comtimcastnews but more
importantly
if you're listening on itunes or spotify
whatever give us a good review it really
does help and if you're not make sure
you check us out on all podcast
platforms
if you find us on itunes or whatever
leave us a good review because it helps
you know just
in general so greatly appreciate it we
do the show monday through friday live
at 8 p.m and of course we'll be back and
we're going to see what we can get done
but of course don't forget to follow at
sourpatch lids who's over there pressing
all the buttons you can't just follow me
at sourpatchlist someone said
no lids no peace on the chat earlier
that's a movement i get behind i like
the sound of that you need like the kids
cheering sound anytime your name is
mentioned
i have no idea what's going to happen
tomorrow but uh people are arriving
right now
as per the news that enrique turner got
arrested so uh
should be interesting nonetheless so
thanks for a little shout out i was
gonna say if you don't wanna know what's
going on tomorrow honestly
there's a lot of journalists that are
out there including myself on twitter at
elijah shaffer drew
honestly if you go to our pages i'll be
tagging a bunch of people
that you can follow during the event
there's about 12 to 15 really reputable
journalists from like center left to
center right
so make sure you you get on twitter
check out tim's tim will be reposting a
lot of the stuff i'm sure
too of what's happening but please like
be on twitter so you can help
keep the narrative straight i know
that's like a weird thing to like
interrupt but just oh yeah
the news is gonna be lying and so please
try to keep people we're going to try to
have a stream from our hotel which
you know we'll be able to uh get clips
from people on the ground if the
internet isn't working all that well
we'll be working with local journalists
we'll bring people up to talk about
what's going on and then
nice yeah so that's the idea so like do
it that's new it's like revolutionary
honestly
doing doing the podcast you know during
the event and then people can come up to
the hotel room and sit down and hang out
and we can talk and we'll be live
the the the issue is that you know often
we have big crowds it's really hard to
get a live stream up a good one
and so sure you have like the the live
stream live view packs the
the bonding agent the cell bonding
systems and stuff
but uh we'll see what we can pull off so
that means we got to send a crew to dc
test the internet make sure it's
possible then we come down and we'll try
and get the show
maybe even tomorrow night we'll see how
things play out but uh at any rate we
will be back live tomorrow at 8 p.m
regardless so come check us out smash
that like button subscribe notification
bell
leave a comment and we will see you all
tomorrow bye guys
you